MonkaW! Mon-Mo-MonkaW!
MonkaW!
O-Ogu!
Oh, ich muss mein Headset entknoten.
Das hat, das, normalerweise hat das, glaube ich, ein 4 Meter Kabel,
das ist ungefähr noch 1 Meter lang.
Seck!
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
So, da bin ich wieder. So muss es sein.
Ja, Leute, wie lief euer Ausbildungsstart?
Falls jemand von euch die Ausbildung angefangen hat.
Ich weiß, dass einige hier im Chat die Ausbildung angefangen haben,
aber ich weiß nicht, ob die schon da sind.
Ich glaube, ich muss erstmal, ich glaube, ich warte nochmal ein paar Minuten, bis ich das frage.
Leute, ich hätte heute fast,
fast 7 Minuten geknackt.
Im Durchschnitt über 6 Kilometer Rennen.
Es geht aufwärts.
Pe-People run.
Donks.
Richtig People run, aber es war nicht ganz, nicht ganz.
Ich habe es nicht ganz geschafft unter 7 Minuten,
aber ich denke mal, wenn ich so weitermache, kriege ich das demnächst hin.
Unter 7 Minuten.
Wenig Stream-Delay. Ich habe überhaupt keinen Stream-Delay eingestellt.
Es sollte nicht nur wenig, es sollte gar keinen extra Stream-Delay geben.
So weit in der Theorie halt, ja.
Real-Time-Streaming.
Michael 50 Billionen, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Eieiei.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Heute richtig People run gemacht wieder.
Aber ich sollte es, glaube ich, nicht jeden Tag so übertreiben,
weil mir tun die Knie schon wieder ein bisschen weh heute.
Nach dem Fach-Abi-Schwerpunkt Informatik
jetzt im Sommer keinen Ausbildungsplatz gefunden.
Bis jetzt und Eltern schmeißen mich bald raus.
Naja, also Eltern sagen viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Also, ich meine, ich kenne deine Eltern nicht, ich weiß nicht,
ob die wirklich so drauf sind, aber
also
vielleicht wollen sie dich auch einfach nur dazu drängen,
endlich was zu machen.
Also bei mir, ich kann es dir noch mal erzählen, wie das bei mir gewesen ist.
Also ich, wie gesagt, weiß ja nicht, wie die drauf sind.
Also bei mir war das auch so.
Ich hatte nach der Schule
hatte ich keinen Bock, irgendwas zu machen. Das habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt.
Nach der Schule hatte ich überhaupt keinen Bock, irgendwas zu machen.
Ich habe ja meine Ausbildung auch erst irgendwie mit, frag mich nicht, 25 oder so gemacht dann.
Also meine zweite, zweite ordentliche Physi-Ausbildung.
Also
ich war mit der Schule fertig und zum damaligen Zeitpunkt
habe ich, ihr wisst, Chat, ihr wisst, was ich gemacht habe, ne?
Ich habe das hier gemacht.
Nice!
Kreiselcrind.
Ich habe MMOs gespielt von morgens bis abends.
Ich habe 24, 7 MMOs gespielt.
Aber
irgendwas mit Holz, ne?
Aber außerhalb von MMOs habe ich nichts gemacht.
Ich bin pennen gegangen und habe dann wieder MMOs gespielt.
Also nix so wirklich.
Und damals haben mich meine Eltern auch ziemlich gedrängt, mach doch mal endlich was.
Such dir doch endlich mal eine ordentliche Ausbildung und fang doch mal an.
Ich war auch vorher beim Arbeitsamt und habe da so eine Berufsberatung gemacht.
Da kam raus, ich soll was mit Holz machen und das war total, total wirr.
Im Endeffekt.
Zumindest, ich habe da noch irgendwann eine Ausbildung angefangen.
Leute, ihr könnt euch das nicht vorstellen.
Business Enterprise Stonks.
Der Max hat eine BWL-Ausbildung gemacht.
Das wissen nicht viele, aber ich habe es euch schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
Ich hatte tatsächlich mal Business Enterprise Stonks BWL-Ausbildung angefangen.
Bis ich dann irgendwann festgestellt habe, dass es überhaupt nichts für mich ist.
Und dann bin ich einfach daheim geblieben, bin ich mehr auf die Arbeit gegangen und in die Schule
und habe weiter MMO-Kreisecrind gemacht.
Und irgendwann haben es dann auch meine Eltern eingesehen, dass es keinen Sinn hat mich weiter zu nerven.
Zumindest, ich habe dann irgendwann Civilians gemacht und tja.
Und dann, und dann tatsächlich habe ich eine Physio-Ausbildung gefunden.
Und da war ich auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Also mach dir nichts draus, wenn du nicht direkt nach der Schule da direkt was findest.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass deine Eltern dir einfach nur ein bisschen Druck machen wollen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie hart sind deine Eltern drauf?
Glaubst du wirklich, die schmeißen dich raus?
Oder das ist eher so eine Taktik, so nach dem Motto, jetzt mach doch was.
Oh ja, hast du doch mal Kaufmann?
Ja, sag ich doch, hab ich doch gerade erzählt.
Ich hab mal BWL, BWL-Zeug gelernt.
Bürokaufmann hab ich gelernt.
Und wie gesagt, ich hab's schon tausend Mal erzählt.
Das Einzige, was ich von dieser Ausbildung noch weiß ist,
die Buchhalter-Nase und dass man linear und degressiv abschreiben kann.
Ich weiß legit nichts mehr sonst davon.
Wie, äh, Hanna CS, Hanna, ich sag einfach mal Hanna.
Wie ausführlich hast du dich denn beworben?
War das wie bei mir, dass du eigentlich gar keinen Bock hast, was zu machen
und haltst dich so nebenbei oder hast du dir wirklich Mühe gegeben?
Sag mal ehrlich, ja?
Wir sind ja hier im Chat auf Twitch.
Hast du dir Mühe gegeben beim Bewerben oder hattest du eigentlich auch keinen Bock?
21, das ist nicht schlimm.
Wie gesagt, bei mir war das genauso.
Ich hab meine erste Ausbildung gemacht nach der Schule.
Wie alt ist man da, so 18, 19 oder so war ich da, glaub ich.
Und das war überhaupt nichts, das war mega kacke.
Und danach hab ich dann irgendwann noch Zivildienst gemacht.
Das gab's ja noch und das war auch noch ein bisschen länger.
Und irgendwann dann mit, ich glaube bei mir auch erst mit 24 oder sowas,
hab ich dann meinen Physiausbildungsplatz gefunden beim Provider.
Und seitdem bin ich Physi.
Ja, das war die Zeit, wo sie dir erzählt haben,
wenn du zu viel CS spielst und generell Spiele,
dass man davon amok läuft.
Da war der Pfeifer, kennt den noch jemand?
Kennt den Dude noch jemand?
Also nicht mit der Bullmütze.
Kennt den noch jemand, den hier?
Kennt ihr den noch?
Anyone?
Kennt den noch jemand?
Regine Pfeifer, die gab's ja auch noch.
Die hat sich dann auch ab und zu zu Killerspielen geäußert.
Ja, der war ein bisschen...
Der war ein bisschen sehr anti-Gaming drauf.
Aber da hat er mit...
Hey, ganz ehrlich, der Typ...
Der Typ hat damit Geld verdient im Endeffekt.
Der war als Killerspiel-Experte bekannt.
Der hat damit Geld gemacht.
Übrigens hier beste Desktop-Backgrounds.
Damit findest du sofort eine Physi-Stelle.
Wenn du sagst, du bist ein Wubblers,
Follower oder Subscriber auf Twitch
und du hast auch die White-People-Happy-Backgrounds.
Instant Arbeitsvertrag.
Yonderboy, danke für den Sub.
Mache zurzeit Umschulung, Anwendungsentwicklung.
Jetzt in 14 Tagen Teil 1 Theorie.
Na dann, good luck, have fun.
Hast du dir schon mal alte Ausbildungs...
Äh, was erzähl ich denn? Nicht Ausbildung.
Hast du dir schon mal...
Ich mach mal kurz ein Update von meiner VM.
Hast du dir schon mal alte Prüfungen angeguckt?
Herr Iser?
Eiser?
Itzer?
Hast du dir schon mal alte Prüfungen angeguckt?
Kann ich dir nämlich nur empfehlen,
wenn du noch keine Ahnung hast,
dann wirst du...
Also, mit keiner Ahnung meine ich nicht,
dass du vom Beruf keine Ahnung hast,
sondern von der Prüfung.
Dann wirst du richtig reinkacken.
Du musst dir alte Prüfungen angucken.
Ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen.
Die beste Vorbereitung auf die Prüfung
ist nicht in die Berufsschule gehen,
ist nicht gut in seinem Job zu sein,
im Betrieb gut zu sein,
gute Projekte zu machen, sonst was.
Der Geheimtipp, um gut in der IHK-Prüfung zu sein, ist,
diese Kack-Prüfung im Vorfeld
sich natürlich nur ganz legal als Sicherheitskopie
irgendwo im Internet zu besorgen
und dann das zu lernen.
Korrekt.
Lol, ich hab damals auch lieber Dark gezockt,
als zur Schule zu gehen.
Ja, besser. Ja.
Oh, dann bist du ungefähr in meinem Alter, hm?
Wenn du Dark gespielt hast.
Ich mein, die ganzen Zoomer kennen ja ordentliche MMOs nicht.
Boomer Max hat gesprochen.
Die haben ja keine Ahnung.
Dark war POG zur damaligen Zeit.
Auf welchem Server hast du gespielt?
So, haben wir alles geupdatet jetzt?
83, ja, ich bin 84.
Ordentlich in MMO kann ich in einem Satz vorkommen.
Klar, Avalon mit.
Hustle, Mauler, Puff, Schaffer.
Das war ein Dark-Meme,
bevor es das Wort Memes überhaupt gab.
Da gab es, ich erkläre euch jetzt,
ich erkläre euch jetzt
20 Jahre alte Nischen-MMO-Memes.
Also.
Es gab damals ein Forum für Dark.
Für das MMO, was ich gespielt hab.
Das war das 4Players-Forum.
Damals war
Foren und so noch angesagt.
Und es gab in Dark mehrere Server.
Es gab Avalon, Stonehenge,
Lioness, Locrest, Dartmoor
und die ganzen englischen Server.
Zumindest haben Leute,
die auf Avalon gespielt haben,
weil man das halt so aus König Arthus und so kennt,
die haben sich für die
super krasse Elite gehalten, teilweise.
Und im Forum
hat irgendein Typ mal
auf irgendeine Noob-Frage
nicht geantwortet,
sondern hat typisch für die damalige Foren-Zeit
geantwortet,
Halt's Maul, hab 50 Ava.
So, und damit war gemeint,
Halt's Maul, ich spiele auf Avalon
und hab nur Level 50er,
was das höchste Level war.
Und das hat sich irgendwie so in Dark,
in der deutschen Dark-Szene durchgesetzt
so als Meme-Antwort.
Immer wenn einer irgendwas gepostet hat
und man nicht wusste, was man drauf schreiben sollte,
hat man damals geantwortet,
Halt's Maul, hab 50 Ava.
20 Jahre Nischen-MMO-Memes erklärt.
Und der Typ
hat sich auch noch verschrieben.
Der hat ja nicht geschrieben, Halt's Maul, hab 50 Ava,
der hat geschrieben, Hasel Maul,
hab 50 Ava.
Mal gucken,
wo kommt man raus, wenn man...
Okay, ich bin nicht
der Einzige, der das noch kennt.
Hasel Maul, hab 50 Ava.
Leute, guckt mal, wie alt ich bin!
Es gibt, seriously,
es gibt 10!
Alter!
10 Ergebnisse auf Google,
das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, 10!
Dann könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
wie alt der Scheiß ist.
Hasel Maul, hab 50 Ava.
Okay, jetzt kommen wir wieder
zum eigentlichen Thema zurück.
Ist Physi-
oder Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration einer Anwendungsentwicklung
nicht offiziell Kaufmann?
Doch, das habe ich auch schon total oft in meinen Videos gesagt.
Laut der IHK
ist sowohl
der Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
der Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung
und
es gibt es nämlich noch neue,
es gibt es nämlich noch unter
Fachinformatik für digitale Vernetzung
unter Fachinformatik für Daten- und Prozessanalyse
die sind
zur Hälfte Kaufmann, laut der IHK.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
wo das herkommt.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, weil die IHK
eigentlich nur kaufmännische Berufe
und keinen reinen Techniker oder so ausbilden darf.
Habe ich mal gehört. Keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Deswegen macht die IHK so einen Blödsinn.
Habt ihr schon mal in Freier Wildbahn
ein Fachinformatiker
Digitale Vernetzung und
Fachinformatiker Daten- und Prozessanalyse gesehen?
Ich nicht.
Ich sehe nach wie vor
Physis und
Phiis.
Ich habe noch nie einen
Phi-Diff und ein
Phi-Dubk
gesehen.
Ja Moment, Moment, ich meine nicht jetzt
in Freier Wildbahn fertig ausgelernt.
Ich meine in der Ausbildung.
Ich habe noch nicht mal eine Ausbildungsstelle dafür
gesehen. Okay, bei euch gibt es
das. Wo liegen die Unterschiede?
Keine Ahnung, das muss die IHK fragen.
Das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Ein Fachabit zu haben
ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt. Da könntest du theoretisch
studieren gehen, worauf ich ja persönlich keinen Bock hätte.
Also, es gibt so ein kleines Problem,
was Fachkräfte
und sowas in Deutschland angeht.
Und zwar, der Titel des Streams heute ist ja,
der hat eigentlich nichts damit zu tun,
was er drüber sagen wollte, aber da passt es jetzt ganz gut.
Der Titel des Streams ist ja heute
Fachinformatiker vs. Fachkräftemangel.
Und es gibt
da so eine kleine Diskrepanz.
Es wollen
ganz viele Unternehmen welche haben,
quasi, sagen wir mal,
mittlere bis Senior
Erfahrung, also sagen wir mal 5 Jahre
plus. Das dumme ist nur,
dass irgendwie noch nicht so ganz angekommen
ist, damit man Leute bekommt, die
5 Jahre plus Erfahrung haben,
dass man auch Leute braucht,
die neue Leute ausbilden
und dass man auch Leute
nehmen muss, die erst angefangen haben
in dem Beruf. Also es
kommt keiner mit 5 Jahren Berufserfahrung
auf die Welt und spawnt,
aber das denken sich halt manche so. Und da gibt es halt
so einen kleinen,
ja, wie soll man sagen,
Realitäts,
falsche Realitätswahrnehmung,
dass es da irgendwie
automatisch
aus irgendwelchen Quellen welche nachkommen,
wenn man selbst nicht dafür sorgt, dass die
nachkommen.
Und das ist natürlich doof und das
ist schwierig. Also ich habe von vielen gehört, es ist tatsächlich
relativ schwierig eine Ausbildungsstelle zu
bekommen und es ist teilweise auch gar
nicht so easy als Berufseinsteiger
wirklich was richtig Gutes zu finden.
Dafür auf der anderen Seite,
wenn du mal ein bisschen Erfahrung hast,
gerade in einem Bereich, was gesucht wird,
dann rennen sie dir die Tür ein.
Es ist halt ein bisschen
wie wir.
Aber ich denke trotzdem hast du ganz gute
Chancen was zu finden.
Hast schon 40 Bewerbungen geschrieben und ein
Vorstellungsgespräch. Nächster Tag Absage.
Okay, krass.
Vielleicht liegt das auch an dem Gebiet?
Also
an der Region?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich bin da tatsächlich
der Falsche für,
was sowas angeht, große Ratschläge zu geben,
weil
wie gesagt, ich habe auch
ausbildungsmäßig die erste komplett verkackt.
Dafür
habe ich
nie viele Bewerbungen geschrieben.
Also ich
habe
für meine
Physi-Bewerbung, also meine
Physi-Ausbildungsstelle beim Provider
habe ich, keine Ahnung, 2 oder
3 Bewerbungen, wenn überhaupt, geschrieben.
Und dann hat das mit der Ausbildung
geklappt und danach wurde ich dort übernommen.
Und danach bin ich direkt zum Nächsten
und dann wieder zum Nächsten.
Und jetzt bin ich halt da, wo ich bin.
Also
ich kenne die Situation aus eigener Erfahrung
nicht, wie es ist, 40 Bewerbungen
zu schreiben und nur Absagen
zu bekommen.
Ich stelle mir das als sehr demotivierend
vor. Auf der anderen Seite,
was ich mir jetzt, also
wie gesagt, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob deine Bewerbung gut oder schlecht oder sonst was.
Ich kann das aus eigener Erfahrung nicht berichten, aber
wenn ich 40 Bewerbungen schreiben würde
und es
kommt nichts, ja,
und es hat nur eine Ausbeute von einem
Vorstellungsgespräch, würde ich mir
zumindest mal überdenken, ob meine Bewerbung,
ob man die Bewerbung nicht vielleicht etwas
geschickter schreiben könnte.
Ach ja, und da würde ich mir keine Gedanken
machen, dass du ein bisschen älter bist. Wie gesagt, ich war auch ein bisschen älter.
Ab letzter Woche erstmal
den ersten Server eingebaut. Käfigmuttern sind
echt Mist. Das stimmt.
Heißen die Dinge
offiziell überhaupt so?
Ich habe die immer Klipse genannt, aber die
heißen ja offiziell nicht so.
Rek-ke-fik
Ja, die Dinger hier.
Genau. Ich habe immer Klipse
dazu gesagt. Ich wusste nie, wie die Dinger richtig heißen.
Das da. Also wenn man da nicht
aufpasst, gehen die ordentlich auf die Fingernägel.
Es gibt aber,
habe ich mir sagen lassen,
habe ich selbst noch nicht ausprobiert,
es gibt neue aus
Plastik, die sich einfacher stecken lassen.
Ich
ähm
Sowas hier war das vielleicht?
Ne.
Keine Ahnung. Ich habe das letztens
irgendwo gesehen, dass das relativ
beliebt ist in der heutigen Zeit,
dass es so neue Rek-Halterungen
gibt.
Aus Plastik.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie die Dinger heißen, ehrlich
gesagt. Sowas hier.
Ja, das meine ich.
Sowas hier.
Ich habe es selbst noch nie ausprobiert
und die sollen deutlich
angenehmer einzubauen sein.
Allerdings wohl nicht ganz
die mega Tragkraft haben,
wie so eine Metall
Mutter.
Die sollen
aber ganz nice sein.
Ich meine, es baut nicht jeder ein Playcenter ein
mit 8 HE an nur
den Schrauben vorne.
Übertrieben gesagt.
Das heißt, für viele Geräte tut das das
wahrscheinlich auch.
Also die sollen wirklich nice sein. Ich habe das jetzt schon
in ein paar Videos
gesehen und gelesen, auch auf Reddit,
dass das zur Zeit relativ angesagt
ist und das wohl auch ganz gut ist.
Aber aus eigener Erfahrung berichten kann ich
nicht. Zumindest macht man sich damit
angeblich nicht die Fingernägel
ab. Oder
quetscht sich den Finger ein
oder sowas. Also das habe ich schon ein paar mal geschafft
bei diesen klassischen
Rek-Muttern, die es früher gegeben hat.
Bei diesen Dingern hier.
Ja, bei diesen Dingern.
Ja, genau
so sehen die aus. Die gibt es aber auch
in verschiedener Güte.
Ich mochte die...
Da musst du in der heutigen Zeit aufpassen, was du sagst.
Ich wollte gerade sagen,
ich mochte die schwarzen nicht.
Wenn das jetzt einer clippt und auf Twitter postet,
was meint ihr, was dann da wieder los ist, Alter?
Keck Alu.
Ich mochte die schwarzen
Rek-Mutter nicht. Ich hatte immer den Eindruck,
die silbernen gehen ein bisschen einfacher.
Ja.
Der Vorteil von diesen Dingern ist halt, die sind
billig. Da kriegst du ein 50er-Set für
ein Apfel und ein Ei. Und Popstar.
Bei Amazon.
Ja, 6 Euro.
Macht Informatikstudium Sinn heutzutage?
Wenn dich das interessiert, klar.
Es ist die Frage,
was dein Ziel ist.
Möchtest du, nennen wir es mal,
so ein bisschen wissenschaftliche Art
zu arbeiten lernen? Möchtest du
viel theoretischen Hintergrund lernen?
Möchtest du beweisen können,
Algorithmenlaufzeiten und sonst was?
Klar, das macht durchaus Sinn.
Es kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Wenn du das einfach nur machen willst, weil du irgendwo
gelesen hast, dass du dann besser verdienst,
kann man machen,
aber ich würde mich nicht darauf verlassen,
weil rein durch ein Informatikstudium an sich
heißt es nicht automatisch,
dass du jetzt der krasse Spitzenverdiener wirst.
Das mag im Durchschnitt sicherlich
so sein. Es gibt bestimmte Statistiken, wo
drin steht, dass studierte Informatiker
im Durchschnitt ein bisschen mehr verdienen als
Physis. Kann alles sein.
Macht bestimmt auch Sinn.
Das muss aber nicht für dich individuell zu treffen.
Das heißt, wenn du Ahnung hast von einem Thema.
Das ist das, worauf es ankommt. Dass du rein auf
ein abgeschlossenes Studium hast, ist
vielleicht beim Berufseinstieg einmal relevant.
Danach bei,
vielleicht wenn du zu einem Amt gehst oder bei ganz speziellen
Positionen, aber ansonsten kommt es
darauf an, dass du was kannst und
Ahnung hast von einem Gebiet, was eben
bei dem jeweiligen Arbeitgeber,
der dich haben will, gefragt ist.
Ob du da jetzt studiert hast oder nicht, ist egal. Also du musst dir
überlegen, warum du Informatik
studieren willst.
Genau, es kommt darauf an, was du machen willst.
Es kommt darauf an, was der Hintergrund ist, warum du das machen willst.
Das kann durchaus Sinn
machen.
Das ist aber nichts, was man pauschal beantworten
kann. Ja, es ist immer gut oder ja, es ist immer kacke.
Ja, das ist gut, dann
wirst du die Prüfung easy schaffen.
Ja, ist so, ist so.
Das einzige Problem, was ich
bisher gehört habe, wenn jemand Umschulung
macht, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange geht denn eigentlich sowas?
Zwei Jahre?
Vollzeit 24
Monate. Also was ich jetzt schon gehört habe,
was bei Umschulung oftmals ein Problem ist,
er muss glaube ich ein
Dreivierteljahr oder ein halbes Jahr,
vielleicht schwankt das auch ein bisschen und vielleicht kann man
da auch ein bisschen
gucken, an die jeweilige Situation
anpassen, aber du musst mindestens ein halbes Jahr, das weiß ich,
ich glaube ein Dreivierteljahr ist es,
musst du davon ein, oder nee, ein halbes
Jahr, ich glaube ein halbes,
doch, ich weiß nicht, ein halbes oder Dreivierteljahr,
musst du ein Praktikum machen.
Und
es scheint relativ schwierig
zu sein, für
Physiumschuldungsteilnehmer
ein Unternehmen
zu finden, was einen
Dreivierteljahres
Physiumschulungs
ja Ausbildungs
Praktikum anbietet,
weil der Sinn von diesem Praktikum
ist, dass du dort dann eben was machst und da
auch dein Abschlussprojekt durchführst und
vorbereitest. Das heißt,
das machen nicht so viele Unternehmen, das ist
glaube ich das Schwierigste an der ganzen
Umschulung, sondern Praktikumsplatz
zu finden. Da hat sich ja meine
alte Firma, wo ich gearbeitet habe, auch nicht, sondern
ich mit Ruhm bekleckert, die sind auch
immer am heulen gewesen, oh nein,
hier Fachkräftemangel, oh nein, wir finden
auch keine guten Azubis und alles so schlimm
und einen, den ich
über fünf Ecken kenne, also quasi der,
lass mal überlegen, wie kenne ich den?
Der Freund von der
Tochter von einer Freundin
von meiner Mutter, also
ich habe mit dem Kerl eigentlich nichts zu tun, ja.
Zumindest, der hat eine
Umschulung gemacht zum Fachinformatiker
und
der hat halt einen Praktikumsplatz gesucht und
ich weiß, dass der gar nicht so wenig
Ahnung hat, also Linux-technisch
ist der wirklich nicht schlecht, das was der mir so erzählt
hat, ich meine, ich mache das jetzt schon seit
15 Jahren, ich
maße mir jetzt an, das halbwegs einschätzen zu können,
je nachdem, was er mir erzählt hat.
Also wenn dir einer aus dem
Kopf Blöcke aus der Nginx-Config
sagen kann, dann hat er meistens schon ein bisschen Ahnung.
So, und
da bin ich damals bei uns zur
Personalabteilung gegangen, hab gesagt, Leute,
wir suchen noch
Nachwuchskräfte und wir suchen noch
Zubis und wir suchen dann halt auch Fachkräfte.
Wie sieht's denn aus? Ich hab hier einen, der hat Ahnung
und der
muss nur noch ein Dreivierteljahr supportet werden
von uns, dann ist der fertig mit der Ausbildung
und wenn der gut ist, habt ihr dann auch gleich jemanden,
den ihr übernehmen könnt
und die haben sich einfach nicht drum gekümmert.
Die haben
das komplett schleifen lassen
und irgendwann musste ich,
ich hab dann mehrfach nachgefragt und es kamen immer
irgendwelche Antworten, so, dann müssen wir erstmal
hier gucken und da gucken und wer
trägt das Geld
und bla bla bla und irgendwann hab ich
dann gesagt, okay, das ist jetzt irgendwie schon ein Monat
oder wie auch immer her, seit ich da gefragt hab,
da hab ich nochmal offiziell über meinen Chef
damals anfragen lassen bei der
Ausbildungsplanungsabteilung
oder wie heißt
es bei den Ausbildungsverantwortlichen da bei uns
und dann hab ich am gleichen Tag
eine Absage gekriegt nach dem Motto, es hätte
sich kein Fachbereich gefunden, der ihn nimmt.
Die haben einfach nur abgesagt, weil mein Chef
nochmal vorbeigeguckt hat und
fuck, fuck, fuck, ich hab eigentlich keinen Bock
und ich will nicht sagen, dass ich mich nicht gekümmert
hab, deswegen sag ich jetzt einfach ab.
Ganz ehrlich, Selbstschuld. Die haben es
nicht verdient, ordentliche Leute zu finden.
Die haben es einfach, die haben
es verkackt. Ganz ehrlich,
denen hast du auf dem Silbertablett
einen guten Kandidat
präsentiert, wo sie nur
minimal hätten Zeit reinstecken müssen
und wollten sie nicht.
Selbstschuld, ganz ehrlich.
Dann sollen sie sich weiter irgendwelche Dienstleistungen
auf Fiverr oder so einkaufen
in Zukunft, wenn sie es so
verkacken. Das ist der
typische Fall von
Job nicht gemacht bei der Ausbildungsvertretung
oder Abteilung damals.
Gibt's immer noch, ja, aber das hat mit dem
was wir gespielt haben in Dark nichts mehr zu tun.
Ich werde, eiser,
vielleicht ist ja auch was für dich, ich werde
entweder wieder Phönix spielen,
Freeshard, wenn der mal an den Start kommt,
oder eben Season 2 Dark.
Also wenn du mal Bock hast, wieder
Dark zu spielen, kann ich dir sehr empfehlen.
Eden ist gerade in der Beta,
wenn, oder
Eden, muss man ja sagen, wenn der startet,
hat es sicherlich wieder 2.000 bis 3.000 Spieler.
Ich habe schon die erste Season gespielt,
paar Monate,
und da habe ich
wieder richtig Bock drauf. Ich brauche einmal
im Jahr,
brauche ich so einen Camelot
Unchained, das habe ich auch gebackt, das wird nie rauskommen.
Ich brauche
einmal im Jahr ein paar Monate
Krassen Dark MMO
sonst halte ich das nicht aus.
Spätestens alle 2 Jahre brauche ich mal so
3-4 Monate am Stück
MMO Kreiselgrind.
Was war das schwerere?
Du musst mir trotzdem erstmal erklären,
warum du das in Erwägung ziehst,
weil das wirkt nicht so.
Also es wirkt für mich so ein bisschen, als willst du halt
das machen, was am Ende mehr Geld gibt, aber
das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Du willst das
einfachste machen, sodass du am Ende
maximale Kohle machen kannst.
Sinnvolle Idee, aber
das
muss nicht so laufen.
Nur weil du ein Studio machst, heißt nicht zwangsläufig, dass du mehr verdienst.
In der Berufsschule hat man
viel Bullshit, das ist korrekt.
Am besten
bei uns in der Berufsschule war immer noch Ethik.
Wir hatten
unsere
Ethiklehrerin, war eine Stunde
da und ist dann 2 Jahre ausgefallen.
Danach hatten wir irgendwie nie wieder Ethik.
Und
dann haben wir alle eine 2 gekriegt.
Und da gab es damals echt noch Leute,
für mich, ich hab die Sache abgehakt,
ich hab mir gedacht, who cares, Berufsschulerin.
Da gab es ernsthaft Leute, die haben dann diskutiert,
warum kriegen wir nur eine 2?
Der Unterricht hat doch überhaupt nicht
stattgefunden und gibt uns doch
allen eine 1. Das waren dann meistens Leute,
die in anderen Fächern es geschafft haben,
beispielsweise in Datenbanken
eine 6 zu schreiben. Es ist mir
immer noch, für heute, komplett
unverständlich, wie man es schaffen konnte,
in der Berufsschule, in einer Datenbank
arbeiten eine 6 zu schreiben.
Doch, ich kenn, wie gesagt,
ich weiß Recycled Story, aber ich kenne
einen, der hat es geschafft, 2 von 100 Punkten
zu kriegen auf einer Datenbankarbeit.
Und der hat zweimal
Create Table geschrieben und dafür hat er 2 Punkte
gekriegt. Der Typ war mega
nice, mit dem hab ich mich richtig gut
verstanden. Und
der hatte einfach den falschen Beruf.
Der hatte eigentlich eine relativ tragische
Background-Story.
Der war früher
Steinmetz und
dem ist im Betrieb
was auf den Fuß gefallen, eine Steinplatte.
Und seitdem konnte er nicht mehr in seinem alten Beruf arbeiten.
Steinmetz war seine Berufung, hab ich eher den Eindruck.
IT war nichts für ihn.
Und da hat sein damaliger Chef,
dort wo er diesen Arbeitsunfall hatte,
hat sich darum gekümmert, dass er in einer Firma
als Physi unterkommt.
Eigentlich nice
von dem Chef, sich da so drum zu kümmern,
aber IT war echt nichts
für den. Das war wirklich nichts für den.
Also, ich glaub, der war richtig
guter Steinmetz, aber nicht sonderlich
guter Physi.
Dabei war das der richtige Giga-Chat, ne?
Der hat nicht viel gesagt,
sah aber übelst, also nicht so
krass schrankmäßig trainiert aus, aber richtig
gut in Form aus.
Und wir haben uns schon immer gedacht, der sieht gar nicht
so aus, wie der typische Physi-ITler
so. Ja? Und irgendwann
kam raus, der Kerl ist
nebenbei.
Ich krieg's nicht mal zusammen, irgendwie in der
Keine Ahnung, irgendwie in der deutschen
Ruder, nicht Nationalmannschaft,
in der hessischen Ruder
Nationalmannschaft oder sowas.
Der war richtig gut. Meinst du, der
hätte mal einen Ton gesagt?
Ich wusste das bis
vor einer Woche, vor Ende der Berufsschule nicht.
Dabei hab ich mich richtig
gut mit dem verstanden. Der hat einfach nie was erzählt.
Das war mega
Giga-Chat, der Typ.
Ich glaube, sogar der hat
im zweiten Anlauf die Prüfung dann bestanden.
Also mit genug Prüfungsvorbereitung
lernen Leute, schafft
jeder die Abschlussprüfung.
Bin ich mir sicher. Und auch
Leute, die die Ausbildung gar nicht
gemacht haben. Es ist egal, wie gut
und schlecht ihr seid,
ihr müsst euch
vorbereiten
auf die Abschlussprüfung.
Und dann geht das.
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
wo der Unterschied bei der neuen Physiausbildung liegt.
20 Jahre
Kubernetes-Erfahrung, das ist auch das Mindeste.
Gut, da weiß ich nicht.
Ich kenn mich nur Hessen
in Frankfurt ein bisschen aus.
Es hat jemand gefragt, hat Max ein Studium?
Nein, hab ich nicht. Wie gesagt, ich hab vor
15 Jahren Fachinformatiker oder über
15 Jahren Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
gelernt. Haben wir da im Chat
IT-Systemadministratoren? Ja, ich
hab das, also mich zum Beispiel.
Ich hab das recht lang gemacht, könnte
man so sagen. Soll ich dir meine
Bewerbung mal im Discord? Nee.
Bitte nicht öffentlich Bewerbungen
mit Namen und so im Discord posten.
Wer weiß, was die Leute damit anstellen. Was du
gerne machen kannst, ist, du kannst das anonymisiert
im Discord posten und fragen, ob man jemand
gucken kann. Ja, klar.
Dachte, du wärst Fulltime-Youtuber.
Quatsch. Hatte ich auch nie vor.
Ja, ist doch nicht verkehrt. Kann man
doch machen.
Wahrscheinlich wirst du damit auf lange Sicht
sogar mehr verdienen, weil du deutlich früher
anfangen kannst, Geld zu verdienen.
Also ich möchte eher studieren,
weil mich viele Themen, die es da gibt,
sehr interessieren, aber ich bin etwas abgeschreckt
von Mathe und Theoretische Informatik. Ja, aber genau
das ist das, was dich interessieren sollte, sonst
macht dein Studium keinen Sinn.
Dich sollte interessieren, wie theoretisch etwas
funktioniert und auch die Theorie
beispielsweise dahinter.
Warum ist
Bubble Sort langsam bei großen Listen?
Wie
funktioniert Quicksort und wie kann man ausrechnen,
dass Quicksort...
Frag mich nicht. Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht,
was die durchschnittliche Laufzeit
von Quicksort ist. Aber ich hab
ja auch nicht studiert, ich muss das ja auch nicht wissen.
Frisch ausgelernter
Physi-Einstiegsgrad in Frankfurt.
Kann ich dir sagen. Easy.
Allgemein
gültig für alle, was
ich jetzt sage, Leute. Und wenn ihr es nicht
kriegt, könnt ihr das klippen und eurem Chef
schicken und dann muss der euch mehr bezahlen.
Ganz klar. Also, was
ich dir sagen kann zu dem Thema ist,
was ich damals bekommen
habe als frisch ausgelernter Physi-
Einstiegsgehalt in Frankfurt.
Und das kannst du hochrechnen
von vor 15 Jahren mit Inflation
und allem an heute.
Ich hab gekommen 33.500
direkt nach der Ausbildung.
Und das war...
Wir haben es letztens ausgerechnet. Ich glaube,
wenn du die Inflation dann mit reinrechnest,
waren das... Leute,
waren das 41,5
oder 42 K oder irgendwie so was.
Wir haben es doch letztens...
Warte mal.
Gehalt-Inflationsrechner.
Wir hatten... Ja. Wir hatten doch
letztens sowas hier.
Ja. Protokoll. Da steht es
doch sogar noch. Guck mal.
Datum der letzten Gehaltserhöhung 2007.
Das wären heute...
Moment. Ist das richtig,
was ich da...
Ja. Genau. Das wären heute
ungefähr 45 K.
Wahrscheinlich wirst du nicht überall so viel kriegen,
aber sagen wir mal als Hausnummern
vielleicht ungefähr 45 K.
Also
da kannst du dir so ungefähr ein bisschen was
zusammenreimen. Und wir hatten
ja auch schon einige im Chat, die
irgendwas
zwischen 40 und 45 K
einstiegsmäßig geschrieben haben.
Und du hast gut...
Du hast in Frankfurt wirklich gut.
Also ich könnte mir
durchaus vorstellen, dass du in Frankfurt noch
die besten Chancen hast,
dass du in Frankfurt noch die besten Chancen hast,
das auch wirklich zu bekommen,
weil Frankfurt und gerade Finanzbranche,
da sitzt das Geld locker.
Und die Konkurrenz ist relativ
groß. Also ich meine jetzt auf
Arbeitgeberseite.
Also die kloppen sich da
eher um die Leute, weil die Händeringen
brauchen.
Also das ist Frankfurt.
Gürtelstraße, Louis Vuitton-Store,
die Kollektion Baaf. Pick auf
Sponsor.
Einzige Sachen von Haftbefehl, die ich auswendig
kann. Ist eigentlich normalerweise nicht
mein Musikgenre.
Aber so ein paar
Sachen kenne ich.
Gefühlt will heute jeder in die IT.
Naja, dafür gibt es aber ganz schön viele, die...
Also nee,
muss ich anders sagen. Dafür gibt es aber ganz schön viele offene Stellen,
für das das jeder in die IT will.
Scheint ja nicht genug zu sein.
Hab Anwendungsentwicklung
gelernt und bereue es nicht Systemintegration
gelernt zu haben.
Ja, ist doch schön, wenn du das Richtige
gemacht hast, für dich.
Letztendlich muss man auch mal
sagen, ja das setzt schon
unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte und
es ist sicherlich auch im Durchschnitt so, dass
Anwendungsentwickler
in Zukunft auch eher im Software-
Entwicklungsumfeld arbeiten
und Systemintegratoren eher
so im Infrastrukturumfeld arbeiten.
Aber es gibt heute immer mehr Überschneidungen.
Der ganze DevOps-Bereich,
der ist ja erst entstanden,
nachdem ich schon lange mit der Ausbildung fertig war.
Eigentlich so eine Sache,
die eher aus dem
Gesichtspunkt kommt,
Entwickler kümmern
sich auch um das Betreiben ihrer selbst
entwickelten Software. Das war so eigentlich
eines der Hintergründe von DevOps, aber
das Ding ist halt,
der Begriff, der hat sich
mittlerweile komplett verselbstständigt.
Und natürlich der reinen Lehre nach
und das gibt dann immer so wichtige
Leute auf Reddit, wenn es dann
drum geht, ah das ist eine DevOps-Stelle,
die dann um die Ecke kommen,
actually, DevOps bedeutet
eine Einstellung und keine
äh, was schreiben die immer?
DevOps ist eine Einstellungssache,
keine Stellenbeschreibung
oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Gibt's dann immer Leute, die müssen sich da super wichtig
aber letztendlich ist es auch vollkommen egal, was irgendwelche
Dudes auf Reddit schreiben, ihr geht
einfach mal auf irgendeine
Bewerbungssuche-Plattform,
gibt, keine Ahnung,
Vollzeit Frankfurt, so,
Homeoffice, perfekt,
weiter, überspringen
und dann sagst du, da suchst du DevOps
und dann wirst du feststellen,
es gibt
Stellen, wo DevOps drin vorkommt, das heißt, es ist
scheißegal, was irgendein
Reddit-Dude schreibt,
dass es keine Stelle ist, sondern eine Einstellung
und bla bla bla, ist egal, es gibt Stellenbezeichnungen,
die das im Titel haben, da ist es egal,
was irgendeine Depp auf Reddit schreibt
und nicht zu wenige, ja,
nicht zu wenige,
Windows DevOps Engine, da würde ich
schon ein bisschen Monka essen, wenn ich das sehe,
ja, Kopie, Moment,
sorry Leute, ich will heute kein
Stellenanzeigen-Stream machen, aber ich will da trotzdem mal reingucken,
Kopie,
Kopie von was,
Homeoffice möglich,
sicher, Lifecycle,
sicher,
CyberArk, cringe,
oh,
ade, azure,
da steht ja fast nichts drin,
jetzt habe ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte,
Leute, CyberArk ist,
naja, cringe war das
falsche Wort, CyberArk
ist eher Painschamp,
CyberArk,
was ich bisher davon gesehen habe, löst bei mir
so ein ähnliches Gefühl aus wie cringe,
so was wie,
ah, hättest es doch nicht gesehen,
wie gesagt, es wächst eh beides
immer weiter zusammen.
Und ich muss auch sagen, das kann ich auch jedem
empfehlen, der heute in der Ausbildung ist, Leute,
schaut über den
Tellerrand rüber, ich habe von
vielen Azubis in der Ausbildung gehört,
so nach dem Motto, eher
Infrastruktur ist gut, aber auf Programmieren habe ich
gar keinen Bock.
Ehrlich gesagt,
aus meiner Sicht wird man auch
ein besserer Admin,
oder wie auch immer,
wenn es nicht fancy genug
Berufsbezeichnung für heute ist,
wie auch immer man sie sich nennen mag,
Infrastructure Engineer,
oder was auch immer,
man wird aus meiner Sicht
ein besserer Admin, wenn man ein bisschen programmieren kann.
Das fängt ja schon da an,
dass du irgendwelche Sachen automatisieren musst,
dazu brauchst du irgendwelche Scripts,
dazu brauchst du irgendwelche Infrastructure
as Code Tools, und ganz ehrlich,
wenn man sich mal
Ansible Playbooks anguckt,
Terraform Playbooks anguckt,
ein paar Bash Scripts, ein paar Python Scripts,
ja das ist Programmieren.
Das mag zwar ein bisschen mehr
Markup lastig sein, was Terraform
und Ansible angeht, aber im Endeffekt
hilft es ungemein, wenn man ein bisschen
Programmierlogik im Hinterkopf hat.
Und außerdem
bin ich bestimmt nicht der einzige,
der fachinformatische Systemintegration
gelernt hat, aber richtig Spaß
an Anwendungsentwicklung hat.
Wie man ja auch im Stream oft genug sieht.
Wir basteln hier, wir haben hier schon alles mögliche.
Wir haben sogar Kobold schon mal im Stream gemacht.
Und wer es mir
nicht glaubt,
und wer es mir nicht glaubt,
wir haben Kobold gemacht im Stream.
Natürlich mit
Comic Sans als Schriftart, das sollte ja
obviously.
Windows Administration, wer macht denn sowas
freiwillig?
Es soll auch Leute geben, die Spaß haben an Windows.
Wie habt ihr
für euch rausgefunden, dass ihr nach der Ausbildung
weiter als Physiker arbeiten
wollt und nicht doch was anderes macht,
weil es Bock gemacht hat?
Man arbeitet ja danach
auch nicht als Physiker weiter.
Fachinformatiker ist keine
Stellenbezeichnung, das ist nur eine Ausbildungsbezeichnung.
Es sucht
niemand ein... okay,
pass mal auf, wir gucken jetzt mal.
Niemand sucht
Fachinformatiker.
Wir müssen halt
Ausbildungsstellen, kann man hier Ausbildungsstellen
wegmachen?
Mit Berufserfahrung.
Moment, es gibt wirklich Leute,
die Stellen suchen mit
Fachinformatiker im Titel?
Das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
IT-Support, MonkaS, Alter.
Gut, aber man sieht schon,
es ist jetzt nicht...
Na, hier ist es auch schon wieder vorbei.
Also, ihr seht,
das sind irgendwie 10 Stellen
oder sowas. Ab hier unten steht es nur noch
im Text.
Das ist hauptsächlich
zur Suchoptimierung nicht, weil die
wirklich jemanden suchen. Also das war es hier im Prinzip
schon.
Also, das ist eigentlich
keine Berufs... das ist nur eine Ausbildungsbezeichnung.
Das ist keine Berufsbezeichnung.
Was du nach deiner Physiausbildung machst,
liegt ganz allein an dir.
Was dir gefällt, was du kannst, worauf du Bock hast.
Am besten natürlich
kommt, was dir gefällt, was du kannst,
worauf du Bock hast, zusammen,
weil...
dann ist für alle das Beste.
Welcher Sort schneller ist,
braucht man da heute? Natürlich braucht man das heute noch.
Also, du magst
das vielleicht
in
großem Teil der Anwendungsfälle
dir da keine großen Gedanken drüber machen,
wenn du die Standard-Library von der jeweiligen
Programmiersprache benutzt, die du verwendest.
So nach dem Motto, hier hast du eine Array,
sortier mal, und dann sagst du,
okay, die werden schon immer das Richtige machen.
Aber wenn du spezielle Anwendungsfälle
hast, kann das
durchaus entscheidend sein,
dass du weißt,
wie du das ordentlich sortierst.
Also, das ist wie immer,
it depends.
Mr. Amek, übrigens danke Leute für die ganzen
Subs. Heute ist ja der... heute ist der
Zweite. Heute sitzen die Prime-Subs
locker, hab ich gehört.
Sind wieder alle Prime-Subs frei geworden.
Mr. Amek, dankeschön.
Jonnyboy, Michael5, spiel hier an.
Pogu Subscriptions. Und gestern hab ich gesehen,
der Vibolo... ne, den hab ich schon vorgelesen.
Aber der Alexander Blum, den hab ich gestern
übersehen.
Danke für die Subs.
Pog.
Lasst doch den Prime-Sub nicht
verfallen. Gebt ihn nicht mir,
gebt ihn irgendjemand anderem auf Twitch, wenn ihr keinen Bock
habt, mir den zu geben. Aber lasst ihn
nicht verfallen.
Auf der anderen Seite, lasst ihn
verfallen, wenn ihr wollt, dass Besos wieder
ins Weltall fliegen kann.
SeriousMarx, danke für den Sub.
Topmodge, top Subscription.
Ja, siehste?
Ich sag doch, Frankfurt IT-Branche geht's ab.
Sucht ihr noch Ausbildungsplätze?
Meinst du dort, wo ich arbeite?
Ja, die suchen immer Nachwuchskräfte.
Aber ich will nicht sagen, wo ich arbeite.
Ja, das ist ja ein bisschen
das Problem, was ich gerade gesagt hab. Das ist ja auch so
das, was der Widerspruch ist.
Viele suchen welche mit Berufserfahrung, wollen aber
selbst nicht ausbilden oder Einsteiger eine Chance geben.
Die denken, die Berufserfahren
spawnen irgendwo. Ich persönlich,
nur so rein egoistisch gesehen für mich,
find ich das natürlich gut, weil ich
hab Berufserfahrung und wenn weniger nachkommen,
kann ich immer mehr Kohle verlangen.
Also wenn's, wenn's danach
geht, find ich das natürlich gut.
Insgesamt find ich's natürlich bescheuert.
TopTopTV, danke für den Sub.
Das ist richtig.
Es gibt viele, die nicht
die du nicht gebrauchen kannst.
Aber das ist ja in jedem Beruf so.
Und es gibt aber auch viele
Stellen, da brauchst du jetzt keinen superkrassen
Spezialist oder so.
Bisschen Active Directory
geklicke oder so. Das kriegt auch jeder hin.
Das würd sogar ich hinkriegen.
Aber ich will das nicht.
Geht mir bloß weg mit
Windows und Active Directory.
Ja, PowerShell ist auch okay.
Trotz Kappa.
PowerShell ist vollkommen okay.
Ja, seh ich genauso.
Es ist immer sinnvoll,
ein bisschen von der anderen Seite zu kennen.
Wie gesagt, als
Infrastruktur-Mensch wird's dir
enorm was bringen, wenn du ein bisschen Ahnung hast von
Anwendungsentwicklung, sei es nur für Automatisierung,
Infrastructure as Code,
Sachen skripten, Sachen programmieren.
Aber auch ein bisschen
zu verstehen, was die Herausforderungen sind
beim Erstellen von
JavaScript-Anwendungen fürs Frontend, Backend,
Java, C Sharp, was auch immer Anwendungen.
Weil du dann besser auch
durch besseres Verständnis
kannst du auch deine Infrastruktur besser designen.
Das bringt
immer was. Und umgedreht bringt es
auch als Anwendungsentwickler was,
sich mit aktuellen
Sachen aus der anderen Richtung zu beschäftigen.
Zum Beispiel, wie baue ich
einen Container? Das muss ja streng genommen ein
Anwendungsentwickler auch nicht wissen.
Wie baue ich einen Container für meine Anwendung?
Aber es ist trotzdem sinnvoll, das zu wissen.
Und vielleicht, wenn er sich damit beschäftigt,
will ich mal kurz was trinken,
hat mich noch keiner dran erinnert, Chatge.
Aber vielleicht fällt jemand dann auf,
dass er seine Anwendung ziemlich doof gebaut hat,
dass sie sich nicht gut vercontainerisieren lässt,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Und dann baut er sie vielleicht anders,
weil er sich damit beschäftigt hat.
Was ist COBOL,
Programmiersprache von
1965 oder so?
Ich habe nichts
gesagt, 1950.
Quasi kurz nach dem 2. Weltkrieg erfunden
worden. Banken
lieben das nicht, Banken haben es halt noch.
Ich komme halt gar nicht hinterher mit dem
Chatge. Ach, Kraft für
EDV.
Das klingt nach einer Ausbildung, die ich nicht machen will.
Turnschuh
admin war beste, ich habe in der Zeit wirklich
sehr viel gelernt. Und ich bin immer noch
beeindruckt, wenn ich dran denke, dass ich
teilweise früher
schneller ins Rechenzentrum bin,
mit einem Server auf der Schubkarre
oder auf diesem Bollerwagen.
Kennt ihr diese Rechenzentrums
Bollerwagen, die sich so kacke steuern lassen,
weil die
Rollen auf der falschen Seite sind, die man lenken
kann? Was ist das für eine Katze?
Recht meine.
Rollwagen
findet man hier nicht.
Weiß nicht, wie die Dinger heißen.
So, aber ich finde es
witzig, dass ich teilweise
mir heute denke, ey, du bist früher
schneller mit einem Server auf deinem Rollwagen
ins Rechenzentrum gefahren, hast den eingebaut,
angeschlossen, gepatcht,
Red Hat DVDs reingesteckt,
installiert
über einen Monitorwagen,
als du heute in der Cloud irgendwas
gebaut kriegst.
Natürlich ist es meistens das komplette Gegenteil.
Aber manchmal denke ich mir auch so,
also alles ist da auch nicht geil.
Ich habe immer
noch glaub 10 offene Emote Slots, ja.
Das ist der wahre
diagonal skalierende
Cloud-Native-Gedanke.
Cloud-Provider
hassen diesen Trick.
Oder eigentlich lieben Cloud-Provider diesen Trick.
TopTopTV,
danke für den Sub. Also
aktuell merke ich davon auch nichts.
IT-Leute sind gefragt, ich kriege
ab nächstem Jahr sogar 5% mehr Geld.
Soll mir alles recht sein.
Natürlich
für insgesamt ist es kacke.
Madminister
Alfred, erinnere mich ans Trinken.
Ja, mache ich auch jetzt.
Was zum Teufel, wie kommt ihr
von IT-Physi-Ausbildung auf
Gendern?
Was ist mit euch
heute wieder los?
Wie
kommt man von einem Thema zum
anderen?
AS400, das kenne ich.
Das sind
IBM-Mainframe-Dinger, oder?
Rollwagen, okay.
Nee, das meine ich nicht.
Diese Dinger meine ich.
Mit solchen Dinger
wurden wir früher rumgeschickt, zum
Server über die Straße karren und so.
Warum kostet
dieser Rollwagen 2800 Euro?
Der ist ja teurer,
als die Hardware, die darauf produziert wird.
Moment,
kostet der nicht sogar 2,7 Millionen
Euro?
Was zum Schnapper.
Ist ja
geschenkt.
Diese Wagen meine ich.
Genau so sehen die Dinger aus.
Die haben die Lenkung
so
komisch
hinten.
Du musst mit den Wagen auch manchmal vorwärts fahren.
So in Fahrstuhl
oder wie auch immer.
Oder raus aus dem Fahrstuhl.
Da kannst du die immer nicht gescheit
lenken, weil hinten die Lenkung ist.
Richtig dumm.
Der Felix und ich, wir haben damals
Loadbalancer über die Straße
gekarrt mit so einem Ding.
Vier Stück, 20.000 Euro
pro Stück, aufeinander
ohne Begrenzung.
Der Gehweg in Frankfurt ist schräg.
Halb runtergerutscht auf die Straße.
Aber einen besseren
Wagen gab es nicht.
Ich mag diese Dinger nicht. Die lassen sich richtig
kacke lenken.
Ja, das Video habe ich auch gesehen.
Werde wohl demnächst meine Physiausbildung
von einem Berufsbildungswerk
anfangen.
Nein, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Von Berufsbildungswerk.
Ihr meint Erfahrung
mit so einem Berufseinstieg?
Ich weiß nicht
wie. Aber ich meine, wenn du eine Physiausbildung
in der Tasche hast am Ende
ist das ja schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Eine ordentliche GitHub-Seite
kann auch nicht schaden.
Man kann auch im Infrastrukturbereich
auf GitHub Sachen machen.
Die AS400 sind
glaube ich auf Aspirin.
Aber was ich meine
ist das Z-Series.
Nein, die
IBM-Dinger.
Solche Oldschool-Dinger.
Kennst du das hier?
Was? Moving?
Moving online web server
using public transport. Das habe ich auch schon
gemacht.
Robert, das Leistungsnetzteil
vor zwölf Jahren.
Ja, da habe ich auch noch server rumge...
Lasst uns da gleich mal
reingucken. Da kann ich als alter Turnschuh-
Boomer-Admin bestimmt was zu erzählen.
Das habe ich auch schon gemacht.
Nicht nur, dass die uns
damals mit dem
Rollwagen über die Straße
geschickt haben, 20.000 Euro pro Stück
Loadbalancer rumzufahren. Wir mussten
auch mit Plates für
Playcenter quer durch Frankfurt mit der S-Bahn fahren.
So, Chat-Gil. Ich habe es gehört.
Lasst uns da mal kurz reingucken.
Ich weiß nicht, was uns erwartet. Video
ist vom Chat.
So, we had to move a server
to a new data center.
It has idled
for almost seven years.
Of course we did not want to ruin the
uptime. Moment, schließen die da jetzt
einen USV an und tragen den durch die
S-Bahn oder was? Moment.
Moment, das müssen wir ja gucken.
Moment, ich habe es gar nicht gelesen.
It had
only one electrical
connection, but at least
two rectifiers.
Full bridge rectifier.
We had to solder a new
power cable to it, which we
inserted. Ah, der hatte zwei Netzteile,
aber nur einen Anschluss und als zweites Netz haben sie
einen USV. Alter, jetzt wird's
jetzt wird's advanced.
Jetzt wird's advanced.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Auto ist in German. Ja, okay.
Was?
Was ist denn das?
Okay, das ist auf jeden Fall was
von vor langer Zeit.
Übrigens, wer hier oben sieht,
dass die Server noch
VGA-Anschlüsse haben, die haben
heute teilweise noch VGA-Anschlüsse.
Also ich erkenne an der Farbe
ehrlich gesagt nicht
wirklich den Hersteller.
Wenn ich mir dieses Board hier
angucke, dann würde ich sogar
sagen, dass es irgendwas
selbst zusammengebaut ist.
Oder vielleicht gehört das hier gar nicht mehr. Ach, Moment,
das gehört gar nicht dazu.
Das ist nur der hier unten, gell? Das da oben ist was
Eigenes. Aber das sieht auch
ziemlich custom aus.
Ist PS2 immer noch dabei?
Also ich bin nicht mehr so oft im
Rechenzentrum, ja? Aber
die letzten Male, wo ich
jetzt ist es auch noch keine fünf Jahre her oder so,
wo ich hier durchgelaufen bin, ja,
auch aktuelle Dell-Systeme
haben noch PS2-Combo-Ports.
Das ist
ein typischer
Boomer-Admin-Humor.
Wir haben hier ein fast redundantes Netzteil mit nur
einem Anschluss. Super redundant.
Ach so, hat doch zwei Netzteile.
Da habe ich ihn falsch verstanden.
Okay, Robert, zeig uns,
was geht.
Leute,
ich sage euch mal ehrlich was, ja?
So cool das heute
mit Cloud-Infrastruktur ist,
ich mochte
diese Bastelzeit
in der IT. Und ich meine
damit nicht unbedingt,
ich mochte die Zeit, in der ich das gemacht
habe, klar auch, aber das gibt es ja heute
so in der Form
nur noch sehr selten. Das findest
du vielleicht noch bei irgendwelchen mittelständischen
Unternehmen, die
irgendwo drei Racks rumstehen haben und sowas
und alles selbst machen.
Und mit einem Admin, der sich um alles kümmert.
Aber ich mochte
die Zeit.
Das hatte noch so
wie sagt man heute?
Hands-on-Mentalität.
Und heute hast du irgendwelche Dienstleister,
die sich ums Rechenzentrum kümmern.
Hast gar keine eigene Infrastruktur
mehr. Hast dich irgendwo
eingemietet, wo du dann nur
noch anrufst, ja könnt ihr mal irgendwo was
stecken und so.
Ich fand die Zeit cool. Und ich bin auch immer gerne
durchs Rechenzentrum gelaufen.
Und
ich hab's ja euch schon
ein paar mal erzählt. Ich konnte
damals, wenn ich morgens, ich bin immer
durch alle, ich bin morgens, weil ich der Erste auf der Arbeit war,
ich bin morgens bei uns in Frankfurt
immer durch die Rechenzentren
an diesem Standort
gegangen. Ja, wir hatten was im sechsten
Stock, wir hatten was im Keller, wir hatten auf der anderen
Seite noch was im Keller. Ich bin da immer
durchgegangen und ich konnte
euch anhand
des Blinkens,
der Farbe und welche
LEDs an waren
sagen, ob irgendwas mit
irgendwelchen Systemen nicht gestimmt hat
oder ob alles okay war.
So oft bin ich da
gewesen und so genau wusste
ich, wie es da aussieht. Und ich
bin da auch immer im Dunkeln durchgelaufen.
Das hab ich auch schon ein paar mal gesagt.
Ich finde, Moment, gibt es hier
im Dunkeln? Gibt es?
Was soll ich denn da suchen?
Datacenter?
Lights off?
Oder?
Nein, so futuristisch
sieht das nicht aus.
Wie auf diesen Bildern.
Gibt es?
Ja!
Das sieht tatsächlich
eher realitätsnah
aus. Ja.
So kann man sich das ungefähr
vorstellen. Rechenzentrum.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so krass hell überall, aber
so kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen.
Rechenzentrum im Dunkeln.
Und ich kann euch wirklich sagen,
wenn man angenommen hier oben
die zwei LEDs auswählen
oder jetzt orange.
Ich wusste damals,
dass das gestern noch nicht so war.
Natürlich hatte man damals
auch schon Systemüberwachung. Damals hatte man
teilweise Nagios und sowas.
Hände hoch, wer noch Nagios kennt.
Ich persönlich mag Nagios.
Ich würde heute kein neues Nagios mehr installieren,
aber ich fand Nagios immer ganz nice.
Natürlich hatte man sowas.
Aber trotzdem war es gut,
das auf den ersten Blick zu sehen.
Und ich mochte das.
Ich fand, das war cool.
Das gibt es heute immer weniger.
Wir haben 37 Minuten geschafft
und ich habe 10 Minuten geschwätzt.
Ihr habt Nagios sogar noch im Einsatz.
Ja, ich meine, warum auch nicht?
Wenn es eine ordentliche Installation ist,
alles abdeckt, was ihr braucht.
Der Riesenvorteil von Nagios ist,
dass es easy erweiterbar ist.
Habe ich es nicht so sehr.
Oder zumindest nur mit sehr viel mehr Pfeife.
Ja, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Leute, das ist halt so ein Ding.
Das ist richtig cool,
so das Ding umzubauen und das dann da hin zu transportieren.
Dann freut man sich richtig.
Das hätte ich heute nicht gemacht.
Sowas wird heute als unprofessionell gesehen,
wenn sowas notwendig ist.
Ja, mag sein, aber es ist einfach
eine coole Zeit gewesen,
wo auch Frickel-IT
irgendwie noch
einen Mehrwert gebracht hat.
Wie soll ich das anders nennen?
Heute würde keiner mehr
auf die Idee kommen,
an einem Surfer selbst rumzulöten,
den in die S-Bahn zu tragen und zu transportieren.
Obwohl das durchaus
in Einzelfällen vielleicht sogar sinnvoll wäre.
Da würde keiner auf die Idee kommen.
Heutzutage würde man
eher den Dienstleister ankacken,
so nach dem Motto
Wo bleibt unser System?
Heute machst du forever Migration.
Ja, das stimmt.
Oder du hast es eh als Container-Workload irgendwo laufen
und machst gar nichts mehr selbst.
Heute wird vieles von dem, was wir früher
gefrickelt haben, als unprofessionell gesehen.
Es war es auch teilweise,
aber es war cool.
Und eins muss ich sagen,
ich hatte den Eindruck,
vielleicht ist es der Boomer, der aus mir spricht,
dass die Leute im Durchschnitt
damals, im Durchschnitt,
es gab genauso gute Flaschen und Überflieger
wie heute, aber im Durchschnitt
besser waren,
was Technik angeht,
als heute.
Aber ist ja auch kein Wunder, wenn du heute mit Technik
richtig in Berührung kommst.
Also mit echter Technik.
Nicht mit einem Web-UI, wo du was anklickst.
Gleichrichter ausgebaut.
Ich habe nur ein paar Schrauben gelöst
und diesen Stecker hier
von der Platine gelöst.
Sagenhaft.
Jetzt muss also Robert nur noch diese Buchse hier auslöten,
über die das Netzteil seine Netzspannung bekommt.
Nico, ich gucke mir das Kommentar
trotzdem gleich an. Erinnere mich nochmal dran,
wenn wir mit dem Video fertig sind.
Dann löten wir noch ein Kabel drauf und dann sind wir schon fast fertig, Robert, oder?
Juhu!
Ja, das ist Henrik.
Und Henrik hält
das Netzteil in der Hand, dass wir
gleich mal den Server entdecken wollen.
Das ist wenigstens auch nochmal so ein schönes
Technik-Raumbüro.
Das könntest du heute gar nicht mehr machen. Ohne Scheiß.
Das sah bei uns damals, also
bei meinem ersten Arbeitgeber,
bei uns sah das teilweise mit Netzwerkequipment
im Büro auch noch so aus.
Heute kommt irgendeiner, der erzählt dir,
oh nein, was macht der hier? Brandschutzverordnung.
Das könnt ihr doch nicht machen.
Es beschwert sich das Reinigungsunternehmen,
dass es nicht mehr hinkommt.
Es beschwert sich irgendein Security-Dude.
Oh nein, du kannst es doch nicht
auf den Tisch stellen. Oh, hier,
da kann ja einer drüberfallen, was da passiert,
was uns das kostet.
Ich fand die Zeit echt cool, ja.
...wollen den wir im Betrieb ungefähr
6-7 Kilometer weit transportieren wollen.
Problem,
Server hat nur eine...
Erstmal die coole, billige Ikea-Steckdosenleiste.
Laut genug, ne?
Ja, Stromverlängerungssystem,
könnte man sagen, für die Hauptstromversorgung des
Servers.
Ein Stromverlängerungssystem, sie haben ein paar
Steckdosenleisten zusammengesteckt.
...von der Firma NTC
hat freundlicherweise eine sehr leistungsstarke
USV...
Genau.
Das, der Typ, das ist
irgendein Sales...
Das haben sie ja geschickt gemacht.
Das ist irgendein Sales-Typ von NTC,
der sich da
ins Video geschlichen hat.
Irgendein Marketing-Verkäufer-Typ von denen.
Guck mal, den siehst du doch
auch schon an, der hat einen Anzug runter und Krawatte.
Das ist eindeutig keiner, der normalerweise
an diesem Serverumzug beteiligt ist.
Das ist irgendein Vertriebstyp von
NTC, der sich da
reingeschmuggelt hat in das Video.
Wir zeigen noch mal,
wie das ganze Gerät dann aussieht.
Auch hier auf dieser Seite schon Werbung.
Jetzt natürlich in Spezialverpackung.
Selbstverständlich.
Für den Weg, der geeignet ist.
Wir sind aufgeregt
und es geht jetzt darum, zu testen,
ob dieses Netzteilmodul mit dieser externen Stromversorgung
des Servers überhaupt funktioniert.
Und sozusagen den Betrieb
des Servers aufrechterhalten kann.
Wenn nicht,
ist das Projekt hier ganz schnell beendet.
Warum piepst denn das Ding so? Weil nur ein Netzteil
drin ist, oder warum?
Boom!
Big Shuck!
Es hat funktioniert,
das Gepiepe ist aus. Das war, weil nur ein Netzteil
drin war.
Wisst ihr, ich finde das cool,
dass die Leute auf so eine
kreative Idee kommen.
Ich stelle mir mal ernsthaft vor,
seriously, ich stelle mir
ernsthaft vor, heute
bei mir
jetzt, wo ich arbeite, wäre ein Meeting
und es würde jemand sagen,
wir müssen einen Hardware-Server
von Rechenzentrum A nach Rechenzentrum B
transportieren.
Und irgendjemand würde dort
ernsthaft vorschlagen, was haltet ihr
denn davon, wenn wir eins von beiden
redundanten Netzteilen ausbauen,
dort ein Kabel
dranlöten, das anschließend
an eine USV den Server
ausbauen, in die S-Bahn laden und ins andere
Rechenzentrum fahren.
Die würden den für komplett verrückt
halten heutzutage.
Dabei ist das doch eigentlich eine
kreative,
sinnige Lösung für das Problem, was die haben.
Switching Network Connection.
We wanted to keep the server online
during the transport. Moment.
Die machen jetzt noch
Mobile Internet mit dem Ding.
Jetzt wird's aber advanced.
Ich dachte, es reicht ihnen schon, wenn der nicht ausgeht.
Die machen jetzt noch eine 3G
Mobilkarte
und dann per OpenVPN.
Okay, jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen.
Jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen.
Ich dachte, es reicht, wenn das Ding anbleibt.
Wahrscheinlich.
Leute, wisst ihr, warum die wollen, dass es anbleibt?
Wahrscheinlich
unter anderem, weil das Ding
Full-Disk-Encryption hat und niemand weiß mehr
das Passwort.
Was wir hier machen ist...
Ist das ein
All-Is-14-Toll-IBM-Notebook?
Ist das noch ein alter ThinkPad?
Man erkennt es nicht richtig, oder?
Wenn es ein ThinkPad ist,
hat es so einen roten Knubbel dran.
Was wir hier machen ist,
wir wollen mit einer
UMTS-Karte...
Du dachtest wegen 100% Uptime.
100% Uptime hat das Ding aber auch,
wenn du es nicht ans Netzwerk anschließt.
Mit Uptime ist ja meistens
die System-Uptime gemeint
und nicht die Service-Uptime.
Zumindest im Serverumfeld.
Wenn die natürlich
die Service-Verfügbarkeit meinen,
dann ist mit Uptime
das gemeint.
Ich hätte eigentlich
mit Uptime eher hieran gedacht.
So.
Diesen Laptop hier
online-sign
mit einer OpenVPN-Verbindung
zu einem Server,
über den wir dann wiederum die echte IP-Adresse
dieses Servers bekommen,
den wir hier heute umziehen.
Bei McDonalds was essen.
Richtig, 2000.
Was hat er denn hier drauf?
Das ist doch ein Gnome 2, oder?
Guck mal. Leiste oben, Leiste unten.
Geht doch nicht.
Das ist doch ein Gnome 2 noch.
Man erkennt es nicht richtig,
das ist noch ein, das ist keine Ahnung,
das ist noch ein
Ubuntu 804
oder so was, was da drauf ist.
Ich hatte übrigens
bis zu meinem letzten Tag
auf der Arbeit, auf der alten Arbeit,
hatte ich noch im Schrank
hinter mir ein ganz altes
IBM ThinkPad
500, boah, 520 oder irgendwie, T520, jawoll, so ein Dick, den mein ich, T520, beste, hatte
ich noch hinter mir so richtig fetten Brocken liegen, hat niemand wirklich verwendet und
darauf war Xubuntu, ich glaub 10.04 oder sowas, oder 12.04 oder irgendwie sowas, wobei 12.04
ist eigentlich fast noch zu neu, da muss 10.04 drauf gewesen sein, Xubuntu genau, mit der
Kiste bin ich immer in sein Rechenzentrum früher rüber und die wollte nie jemand wieder
haben, deswegen, hätte ich gedurft, hätte ich die mitgenommen, als Andenken.
Meint ihr, ob noch Zeit ist nachher, irgendwo bei McDonalds was essen zu gehen?
Mit dem Server, ne?
Ja.
Ja, klar.
Klar, einfach das Telekom-WLAN zu hacken.
Der Wagen ist prädestiniert.
Breites WLAN ist doch top.
Für MacDrive-Einsätze.
Let's pull out the server and get ready for the transport, okay.
Bisschen laut, Leute, oder?
Mit dem Stecker.
Ah, eine gute Zwischendecke.
Oder Zwischen, nicht Zwischendecke, Zwischenboden.
Komm, wir fahren mal.
Sauber.
Wir nehmen den Wagen, oder?
Wir nehmen den Wagen.
Nett, nett, schlecht, Leute.
Wir müssen etwa einen Kilometer bis zum Subway-Train fahren.
Das wird uns noch kein anderer.
Würde ich behaupten.
Ja, da gehen wir ins Rödings-Markt.
Wir gehen ins Rödings-Markt.
Das muss nicht unbedingt Nacht sein.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass es spät am Tag ist, aber es kann auch einfach im Winter sein,
wo irgendwie schon gefühlt ab 14 Uhr dunkel wird.
Es ist aber von Vorteil, es nicht unbedingt zu Stoßzeiten im Berufsverkehr zu machen,
wenn du mit so einer Kiste durch die S-Bahn willst.
So, wie wir sehen, es ist jetzt 5 vor 8.
Es regnet auch noch.
Wie gesagt, wir sind auch schon mit IBM Plates unter der Jacke durch die S-Bahn gelaufen,
um dann rauszugehen, weil es geregnet hat.
Also unter der Jacke, weil es geregnet hat.
Berliner Tor.
Wo sind denn die?
Ich meine, nur weil da Berliner Tor steht, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass die in Berlin sind.
Wir haben 20 Uhr.
20 Uhr.
Hamburg.
Haben sie gesagt, echt?
Nice.
Guck mal, wie sie da so ein Zelt aus durchsichtigem Plastik gebaut haben,
dass der nicht nass wird.
Ey, das sieht aus wie ein Krankentransport, oder?
Guck mal, mit den Kabeln und alles.
Da denkst du, da liegt einer im Koma drunter, so nach dem Motto.
Und er wird gerade transportiert von einem Krankenhaus ins andere.
Irgendein Unfallopfer liegt da drunter, wird beatmet.
Herztransplantation am Laufen.
Vorsichtig mit dem Wasser.
So, wir sind angekommen, Berliner Tor.
Vielleicht kann man das ja sehen.
Berliner Tor sieht man vorstellen.
Genau.
Weißt du, das ist so ein Ding, das erzählen die sich heute noch.
Das erzählen die sich heute noch, und wenn die irgendwelche Azubis haben,
kriegt jeder Azubi von jedem der Beteiligten, falls die noch da sind,
diese Story einmal monatlich erzählt.
Das ist so ein typisches Ding, das erzählt zu ewig.
An jeder Weihnachtsfeier mindestens.
Einmal am Sommerfest, einmal an der Weihnachtsfeier kriegen das die Leute erzählen.
Und die neuen fünfmal, dass sie es nicht vergessen.
Hammerkirche.
Ist die so geil, die Kirche?
Guck mal, haben die so einen geilen Rollwagen, wie ich vorhin beschrieben habe?
Ist das etwa so ein Poggers Rollwagen?
Ja, sieht ein bisschen so aus, wie ein dieser Hornbach Rollwagen,
den ich euch vorhin gezeigt habe.
Ja, genau, das ist original so ein Ding.
Ich sehe, nicht nur wir hatten diesen Kram am Start.
Die tragen da 70 Kilo OSV, ja, let's go.
Als Turnschuhadmin musst du ein bisschen was tragen können.
Stimmt, Leute, Leute, wo ist das Elektrostatik-Armband?
Das kann ja so gar nichts werden.
Bin gerade dazugekommen, um was geht es?
Das ist ein Video von vor zwölf Jahren.
Die transportieren einen Server von einem Rechenzentrum ins andere.
Und zwar ohne, dass der Strom ausgeht und ohne, dass die Internetverbindung abbricht.
Dazu haben sie eine fette OSV angelötet
und ein Handy mit einer 3G-Verbindung angeschlossen
und sich per OpenVPN verbunden, dass die Public IP gleich bleibt.
Wow, wow, Alter, erschreck mich nicht so.
Und warum dann mit öffentlichem Verkehr?
Das ist eine gute Frage, keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es die einfachste Variante ist.
Ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Warum mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Porto Luz wahrscheinlich, genau.
Leute, Leute, was fällt euch an diesem Bild auf?
Was in der heutigen Zeit nicht möglich gewesen wäre.
Ich meine, der hat eine Uhr an.
Niemand heute, außer ich mit meiner Fitnessuhr manchmal und ein paar andere, hat Uhren.
Das war pre-Smartphone-Zeit.
Smartphone-Zeit.
Da haben die Leute auf Uhren geguckt.
Die meisten Leute haben heute keine Uhr mehr an.
Die haben nur ein Handy. Ein paar super stylische haben eine Apple Watch oder so an.
Und ich habe tatsächlich meine Fitness-Tracker-Uhr an.
Aber ansonsten, ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher, ob das Video wirklich von 2012 ist.
Äh, von 2010.
Also 2010 waren Smartphones definitiv noch nicht groß verbreitet.
Ich glaube, das iPhone wurde 2008 vorgestellt.
Und das hat ja dann auch ein bisschen gedauert.
Damals gab es noch nicht mal einen App-Store.
Also 2010 war das definitiv noch nicht Mainstream.
USV schockt es gar nicht.
So eine heiße Echse.
Jetzt müssen sie es zwei Kilometer tragen.
Viel Spaß, 70 Kilometer.
Ach ne, die haben ja den Wagen drunter.
Und es regnet auch noch.
Wobei, das haben wir ja schon gesehen, aber trotzdem.
Mal gucken, ob die Plastikkonstruktion...
Ey, das sieht wirklich aus wie Patiententransport vom Krankenhaus ins andere.
Nur noch wenige hundert Meter vom Ziel.
Und jetzt hinfallen.
Präge.
Nicht hinfallen, nicht irgendwie was rausziehen, weil man nicht aufpasst.
Okay, sie haben ziemlich genau eine Stunde gebraucht für den Transport.
Moment.
Ich dachte, die USV ist das untere Netzteil.
Oder nicht?
Nice.
Das haben sie doch richtig gut hingekriegt.
Easy Clap.
Man versteht kein Wort, Leute.
Übrigens typischer, nicer RZ-Sound.
Datacenter-Sound.
Nice.
Das war ein cooles Video.
Gibt es die heute noch?
Also die...
Diese Firma.
IPHH.
Aha, wahrscheinlich für Hamburg.
Oh, die sehen heute aber deutlich moderner aus.
Über uns.
Naja.
Auf jeden Fall, das war wirklich ein cooles Video.
Sowas gucke ich mir gerne an.
Vor allem, weil es mich immer selbst an die eigene Turnschuh-Admin-Zeit erinnert.
Ob das Server noch läuft?
Ja, wir wissen ja leider nicht.
Wir wissen ja leider nicht, welche Seite es gewesen ist.
Hat er noch andere Sachen? Nee.
Mega Video.
Das hat mir richtig gut gefallen, Chat.
Die suchen Mitarbeiter.
Sollen wir da jetzt mal gucken?
Wie hießen die?
IPHH?
Über uns. Zeigt mal Jobs.
Wir müssen übrigens im anderen Browser gucken.
Wo war das, Leute? Jobs?
Ja, Job-Angebote.
Okay, mal auf die Schnelle. Mal ganz kurz drüber scrollen.
Viel angucken werde ich mir das nicht.
Linux System Engineering.
Ja, genau das Richtige für mich hier.
Pogu.
Was wollen die da haben?
Als Linux System Engineer arbeiten sie bei uns in einem kleinen, hochqualifizierten Team.
Weitere Administratoren, verschiedene Kundenprojekte und internen System.
Sie planen und implementieren Serverlösungen von Einzelsystemen bis zu vollredundanten Clustern.
Dieses kann die Planung zu ...
Blablabla.
Schwerpunkt bei Servern ist im Debian.
Der Laden ist mir gleich sympathisch.
Mit verschiedenen Applikationen im Bereich Load Balancer F5.
Ja, okay, wenn es sein muss.
Äh, so, Nginx, okay.
Sie arbeiten bei uns im Team der Systemadministration.
Die Arbeit mit Kollegen und Kunden macht ihnen Spaß.
Das hängt nicht unbedingt generell an der Arbeit, sondern von den Kollegen und den Kunden ab.
Wieso nicht Arch auf dem Server? Weil das keiner macht, der beiverstand ist.
Sie verfügen über mehrere Jahre detaillierte Erfahrung der Linux System Administration.
Im Bereich von Webdiensten.
Apache Nginx plus SSL.
Die Stellenanzeige liest sich auch ein bisschen wie vor 10 Jahren, aber das finde ich gut.
Vielleicht, weil ich das Video im Hinterkopf noch habe, ja.
Hochverfügbare Linux Systeme mit Load Balancer.
Ja, noch MySQL Postgres.
Shell, Perl. Okay, definitiv oldschool.
PHP oder Python.
Xen oder KVM.
Libvirt.
Schön, dass sie sogar Libvirt dabei schreiben.
Ich meine, die meisten Leute schreiben noch nicht mal KVM dabei.
Schreiben da einfach Virtualisierungslösungen.
Sie haben praktische Erfahrung mit Automatisierung, mit Ansible.
Oder sind motiviert, dieses kennenzulernen.
Wenn sie über Wissen zu Storage Systemen NetApp oder EMC verfügen, wäre Pluspunkt.
IP Netze, 24-7 Rufbereitschaft. Naja, wenn es sein muss.
Sie sprechen im Grunde englisch. Okay, wir bieten Vertrauenskultur.
Reichlich kostenlose Getränke.
Guck mal, sogar per GPG verschlüsselt.
Das wollen die wenigsten.
Also akzeptieren die wenigsten.
Ich glaube, die machen heute immer noch ordentliche Turnschuh-Administrationen.
Man kriegt bestimmt einen Bonus, wenn man es verschlüsselt verschickt.
Glaube ich auch. Also nicht einen Bonus im eigentlichen Sinne an Geld, sondern einen.
Pluspunkt für die Bewerbung.
Kriegt man.
Was können wir uns denn sonst noch angucken, Leute? Wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Wiley, wobei wir müssen...
Moment, Moment, Moment. Das will ich mir nicht...
Oh ne, das gucke ich mir nicht an.
Das ist der Typ, der sagt, er will kein Firefox mehr benutzen und dann zwei Monate später wieder Firefox verwenden.
Was ist das?
I spent six months rewriting everything in Rust.
Ich will nicht everything in Rust rewriten.
What's on my smart homelab server?
Ah, vielleicht.
Starfield-Test.
Eine App entwickeln. Was ist das?
Ah!
Der Golo!
Ich habe ja immer noch die Vermutung, dass Golo ein Echsenmensch ist.
Der plinzelt immer so. Ich habe das genau gesehen.
Keck Alu.
IT-Zertifikate.
Bessere Chancen bei der Jobsuche.
Das könnte tatsächlich thematisch heute gut in den Stream passen.
Also ich sage euch mal kurz, was ich zu Zertifikaten denke.
Ich denke, dass Zertifikate in aller Regel nichts bringen.
Es gibt eine Ausnahme.
Ich halte dieses ganze Zertifikats-Ökosystem so ein für sich selbsterhaltendes, mit Geld versorgendes Ökosystem.
Sei es jetzt DIN ISO 9001 Qualitätszertifizierung oder Zertifikate zu, was weiß ich, Microsoft Office.
Das ist alles nur dazu da, um Kohle zu machen in diesem Ökosystem.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich als Arbeitgeber Wert legen würde auf ein Zertifikat ist, wenn ich sicherstellen will, also wo tatsächlich ein Zertifikat von Vorteil wäre.
Wenn ich sicherstellen will, dass derjenige auch wirklich ganz grundlegende Skills hat in dem Bereich, wo ich was suche.
Und ich meine damit jetzt wirklich grundlegende Sachen.
Also wenn zum Beispiel einer mir ein LPig vorlegt und der LPig ist gar nicht mal so super einfach.
Zumindest das war ich, ich habe selbst keinen, das war ich davon gesehen habe.
Also wenn mir einer ein LPig Zertifikat vorlegt, dann würde ich das einzig und allein nur aus dem Grund gut finden, weil ich wüsste, okay, ich kann mir sicher sein, der Typ hat auf jeden Fall ganz grundlegende Ahnung von Linux.
Das kann ich aber auch mit einem ordentlichen Bewerbungsgespräch eigentlich rauskriegen.
Aber wenn ich im Vorfeld das rausfiltern möchte und ganz sicher, aber da würde ich wirklich nur, wenn ich darauf gucken würde, wirklich nur, um sicher zu sein, dass ich da nicht jemand hinsetze, der bisher nur, keine Ahnung, Wände tapeziert hat.
Ja, da habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht, ja, ja, vielleicht.
Wobei du in der Zeit wahrscheinlich besser ein Projekt mit der Technologie umgesetzt hättest, besser Bescheid wüsstest und auch wüsstest, wovon du redest, aber okay.
Weil nur, weil man ein Zertifikat hat, heißt es ja noch lange nicht, dass man weiß, wovon man redet.
Deswegen sage ich ja, das geht darum, dass man wirklich sich sicher sein kann, dass die ganz, ganz Basics der Basics vorhanden sind, nicht mehr.
Ein Punkt von LP1 ist, eine Linux Workstation einschließlich X11 installieren, warum kein Wayland?
Wahrscheinlich machen die es in der VM und Wayland funktioniert nicht gescheit im VMware.
Oder sie sind einfach komplett outdated, overrated, gebated.
Okay, dann schauen wir uns doch mal an, ja, dann schauen wir uns doch mal an, was er dazu zu sagen hat.
Ich mach mal kurz die Musik aus.
Ich gucke übrigens die Videos sehr gerne von ihm.
Er macht hauptsächlich Sachen über Frontend-Entwicklung und Backend-Entwicklung in Go und generell so ein bisschen Architektur und allgemeine, ja, wie soll ich sagen, Open Source Themen.
Immer aber auch sehr, sagen wir mal so, praktisch bezogen ist das falsche Wort, sehr Business bezogen.
Gut, ich meine, das ist eine, der ist der Gründer von einer Firma, die, ja, Technologie-Sachen verkauft, also im Prinzip, ja, weiß nicht, was die eigentlich genau machen.
Also, natürlich hat er da Business-Sicht, aber ich gucke die Videos wirklich gerne, weil du merkst bei dem, der weiß, aus der praktischen Erfahrung, wovon er redet.
Und ich gehe da auch oft d'accord mit dem, was er sagt.
Das hier ist beispielsweise auch was, was ich ganz genauso sehe.
Hat jemand von euch den Stress mit Mock mitbekommen?
Dieser .net-Library, weiß gar nicht, wie das jetzt ausgegangen ist.
Ich habe es auch nicht verstanden, wie da die Leute wieder den kompletten Weltuntergang herbeigeredet haben.
Allerdings, ja, ich verstehe, dass man es nicht unbedingt benutzen möchte, aber auf der anderen Seite, also es war wieder viel zu übertriebener Shitstorm.
Genauso wie jetzt bei der Terraform-Lizenzänderung.
Bei der Terraform-Lizenzänderung ist auch wieder Weltuntergang herbeigeredet.
Nee, wieso?
Okay, also Mock ist eine Library für .net, das ist vollkommen egal, wofür die da ist.
Und der Autor der Mock-Library, komm Max, sag mir schon für den Sub.
Exzellent, schön, dass du hier bist. Das ist extremely Pog.
Ja, also Mock ist eine Library für .net.
Und der Autor von Mock hat eingebaut in diese Library, dass die Git-Config gepasst wird.
Und geschaut wird, während man ein Bild macht von einem Projekt, wo die Library hinzugefügt wurde.
Die Library liest während dem Bildprozess die Git-Config aus und liest die E-Mail-Adresse aus.
Und schaut, ob der Entwickler ein Sponsor des Projektes ist, anhand der E-Mail-Adresse.
Anhand der E-Mail-Adresse.
Und wenn der Entwickler ein Sponsor des Projektes ist, dann zeigt er eine Dankeschön-Message an, so im Endeffekt.
Das ist das, was der Mock-Entwickler gemacht hat.
Damit das funktioniert, muss er natürlich das Ganze abgleichen.
Und der schickt die E-Mail-Adresse gehashed an einen Server, um abzugleichen, ob das ein Sponsor ist.
Das hat extremen Aufschrei in der .net-Community dafür gesorgt.
Ich finde auch, der Autor ist darüber hinaus geschossen über das Ziel, ungefragt E-Mail-Adressen benutzt zu machen.
Ich weiß übrigens nicht, ob das mittlerweile schon behoben ist.
Also der hat auf jeden Fall ziemlich krassen Image-Schaden davon getragen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, dass man sich irgendwie Gedanken machen muss um Open-Source-Monetarisierung, ist verständlich.
Und dass jetzt Leute herkommen, das ist das meiste, was mich dabei eigentlich aufgeregt hat.
Dass Leute jetzt herkommen, die diese Library seit 10 Jahren benutzen, kostenlos.
Und darauf wirklich teure Enterprise-Business-Software-Produkte mitgebaut haben und gut Geld verdienen.
Dass die jetzt auf GitHub hingehen und den Typ übelst fertig machen für diese Entscheidung.
Ich kann es verstehen, dass sie es nicht mehr verwenden wollen.
Hey, jeder seine Entscheidung.
Aber die Kommentare sind so selbstgerechter Bullshit gewesen auf GitHub.
So als hätten sie durch das pure Benutzen der Library irgendeinen moralischen Anspruch darauf,
dass der Autor sich jetzt gefälligst kostenlos für alle Zeit nach ihren Vorstellungen um diese Library kümmern muss.
Und das ist was, das ist mir da auch schon sehr sauer aufgestoßen.
Und da muss ich sagen, da bin ich hier mit Golo auch wirklich d'accord gegangen, was er in dem Video gesagt hat.
Natürlich kann man sich dafür entscheiden, aus solchen Gründen die Library nicht mehr zu verwenden.
Das ist sogar verständlich, kann ich alles nachvollziehen.
Vielleicht würde ich das auch nicht machen, wenn ich die in einem Business-Kontext verwende.
Ich glaube mittlerweile ist das sogar schon wieder rausgepatcht, also halb so wild.
Da gab es dann irgendwelche Leute, die haben das geforkt.
Die werden dann früher oder später feststellen, ja ist halt auch dumm.
Jetzt hat er es geforkt, jetzt darf er sich kostenlos um die ganze Sache kümmern.
Außerdem setzen sich so Forks eh relativ selten durch, weil die dann meistens aufgehört werden zu maintainen.
Die werden dann meistens nicht mehr maintainen nach ein, zwei Monaten.
Ja, und genauso bei der Terraform Lizenzänderung.
Ja, ich finde die Terraform Lizenzänderung auch doof.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz musste ich schon gucken, wie kannst du Open Source ordentlich monetarisieren.
Und ich verstehe den Riesenaufschrei nicht, weil Terraform ist immer noch Open Source.
Terraform ist immer noch kostenlos verfügbar.
Du kannst mit Terraform mehr oder weniger immer noch alles machen, was du willst.
Das Einzige, was du nicht machen kannst ist, mit Terraform ein Terraform Konkurrenzprodukt herstellen.
Was ich nachvollziehbar finde, dass Heschikop das nicht will.
Natürlich ist dementsprechend Terraform kein richtiges Open Source Produkt mehr nach der Definition der, wie heißen die Typen, Open Software Foundation.
Aber ey, der Aufschrei ist einfach wieder viel zu groß und viel zu übertrieben gewesen.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich finde er macht wirklich gute Videos und ich stimme ihm auch bei vielem zu.
Deswegen gucken wir uns mal an, was Golo sagt zu Zertifikaten.
Meine Meinung zu Zertifikaten habe ich euch doch gerade schon erzählt.
Das heißt, schauen wir mal.
Kurz oder lang das Unternehmen zu wechseln.
Was?
Vielleicht spielst du aktuell mit dem Gedanken über kurz oder lang das Unternehmen.
Laut genug, passt.
Ja, Madminister, das ist schon richtig.
Das kann man letztendlich aber über fast jedes Open Source Projekt sagen.
Natürlich profitieren beide Seiten von.
Aber ich würde tatsächlich sagen, dass die Anwender von Terraform unterm Strich mehr profitieren.
Natürlich kann Heschikop Geld machen, auch mit Contributions.
Aber dadurch, dass es Open Source ist, haben ja alle was von den Contributions.
Also insofern, ich kann es irgendwo nachvollziehen.
Und es ist nicht der Weltuntergang, wie das herbeigeredet wurde vor ein paar Tagen.
Und ob der Terraform Vorklange hält, ich wage es zu bezweifeln.
Okay, Zertifikate.
Vielleicht spielst du aktuell mit dem Gedanken über kurz oder lang das Unternehmen zu wechseln.
Habe ich schon, seit April.
Ohne Zertifikate.
Unweigerlich verbunden ist, ist eine Bewerbung.
Und vielleicht liegt deine letzte Bewerbung auch schon einige...
Bisschen lauter könnten wir es noch machen, oder?
Jahre zurück und höchstwahrscheinlich bist du nicht übermäßig geübt darin, dich zu bewerben.
Denn du machst das ja schließlich nicht ständig.
Und du weißt aber auch...
Das ist korrekt, ich war auch nicht sonderlich geübt darin, mich zu bewerben.
Aber es hat glücklicherweise ganz gut funktioniert.
Dass der erste Eindruck wirklich sitzen muss.
Ja. Das stimmt wohl.
Dass du in einem Unternehmen praktisch nur eine einzige Chance hast.
Und naja. Das stimmt wohl.
Was ist da unten?
Angst, aber es bereitet dir doch zumindest irgendwo Sorgen.
Du gehst nicht so unbeschwert in den Tag, wie du es normalerweise tun würdest.
Du machst dir viele Gedanken.
Und wäre es da nicht hervorragend und vor allem sehr beruhigend, wenn du deiner Bewerbung einfach...
Ich wurde im Vorstellungsgespräch gefragt, was müssten wir machen, um sie so richtig zu ärgern.
Und ich habe darauf geantwortet, Windows administrieren.
Ich finde vollkommen valide, legit Antwort.
Aber irgendwie war das nicht das, was der Personaler hören wollte.
...beifügen könntest, quasi eine Art geheime Zutat, die dich dermaßen...
Komm, 1008 SP reicht.
...durch die anderen Bewerberinnen und Bewerber abhebt, dass du den Job eigentlich schon sicher in der Tasche hast.
Und genau diese geheime Zutat, das sind Zertifizierungen.
Zumindest behauptet das die Werbung.
Und was da dran ist, wie sinnvoll Zertifizierungen sind oder ob sie vielleicht gar nicht so sinnvoll sind, darum geht es im heutigen Video.
Und in diesem Sinne...
Bin ich mal gespannt, was er sagt.
Herzlich willkommen zu unserem neuen Weekly.
Meine Meinung zur Zertifizierung kennt ihr jetzt, ja.
Bevor wir in das Pro...
Genau. Ich habe rein aus Umweltschutzgründen, Leute.
Umweltschutz. Wir reduzieren das jetzt auf 720p.
...wo die Zertifizierungen historisch gesehen eigentlich herkommen.
Und mit dem Strom, den ich spare, lade ich mein Elektroauto auf.
Wie man meinen könnte, stammt nämlich tatsächlich schon aus den...
Safe. Jetzt Umweltverschmutzung erfolgreich besiegt.
...70er Jahren, denn damals...
Ich muss sagen, das Video sieht mit 720p und 1080p gar nicht so unterschiedlich aus, gell?
...fingen Computer an, sich nach und nach in Unternehmen zu verbreiten.
Und dementsprechend stieg damals dann parallel auch der Bedarf an entsprechend geschultem Personal.
Wobei sich das zunächst vor allem erstmal auf Hardware und Netzwerktechnik bezogen hat.
Hat der eine Apple Watch?
Ist das eine Apple Watch, Leute?
...ja doch noch relativ jung im Feld. Schwierig war, einzuschätzen,
wie gut sich jemand wirklich auskennt, kamen die Hardwarehersteller und die Netzwerkausrüster
dann auf die Idee, Zertifizierungen anzubieten.
Cisco war ja... Also Cisco und Zertifikatsbusiness, die sind ja der eine oder der größte.
Ich meine, Cisco hat ja gefühlt 150 Zertifikate, die alle irgendwie ähnlich heißen.
Geht los mit dem CCNA. Gibt's denn überhaupt noch dann irgendwie CCNP und CCA?
Boah, keine Ahnung, Alter. Cisco hat gefühlt 150 Zertifizierungen.
Ich hab auch mal nen CCNA gemacht vor Urzeiten.
Und seriously, ich hab so lange nix mehr mit Cisco Command Line zu tun gehabt.
Ich weiß nichts mehr. Ich weiß noch, dass man EN machen muss als erstes,
wenn man sich einloggt, für Enable. Und das war's. Mehr weiß ich nicht mehr.
Doch, Fragezeichen. Fragezeichen am Ende, um Hilfe anzuzeigen.
Und W ist wenig Konfigurationsschreiben? Oder Save? Ja, ich weiß es nicht.
Nee, Moment. Cisco Konfigurationsschreiben ist doch so komisch. Copyrunning zu Save oder sowas.
Copyrun Start, ja. Ja, ja, sowas, genau. Aber mehr weiß ich davon echt nicht mehr.
In den 1980er Jahren kam dann nach und nach Software dazu, wobei es zunächst
um relationale Datenbanken und Netzwerkbetriebssysteme ging.
Und in den 1990er und frühen 2000er Jahren dürfte dann mit der damaligen Dotcom-Blase
wohl der vorläufige Höhepunkt erreicht gewesen sein.
Denn da sind dann auch Unternehmen wie Microsoft, Oracle, Cisco und wie sie nicht alle heißen,
Leute, jetzt, weil er es gerade gesagt hat, immer wenn ich Dotcom höre,
wisst ihr, woran ich dann denken muss?
Mega Upload. Irgendwie muss ich da immer dran denken, wenn ich Dotcom höre.
Files across the globe. I use Mega Upload.
Das ist auch schon elf Jahre her, Leute, Mega Upload.
Die Typen im Video hatten keine Ahnung, um was es in der Werbung geht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du gestrikt wirst für die Mega Upload-Musik.
Okay, genug jetzt. Wir gucken das Video weiter.
Leute, ich weiß, ihr seid noch ein bisschen jünger.
Jemand von euch noch Mega Upload benutzt?
Okay, ich lasse das mal kurz weiterlaufen.
Wir reden kurz über Mega Upload.
Leute jung genug für Mega Upload?
Für Mega Upload?
Ja, okay, okay.
Leider haben die Leute das schon vorweg gegriffen.
Ich wollte jetzt noch was Nächstes fragen.
Wer ist alt genug, Rapid Share noch benutzt zu haben?
Rapid Share-User am Start hier, Leute?
Hände hoch, Rapid Share-User.
Rapid Share?
Rapid Share hat ein bisschen die Arschkarte gehabt,
weil es ein File-Hoster war.
It's a hit.
Natürlich habe ich das nur für Backups.
Backups, Linux-Distributionen und Sicherheitskopien verwendet.
Obviously.
Ja, das war noch was.
Geocities?
Ne.
Also ja, das kenne ich noch.
Wie heißt das noch?
Treepod und Lycosites und sowas.
For free.
FDP-Server.
Naja, Leute, in den 2000er-Jahren,
wenn man eine Webseite hosten wollte,
Sach genug jetzt.
In den 2000er, wenn man eine Webseite hosten wollte,
da hast du nicht einfach dir irgendeine Cloud-VM professioniert,
as a service in einem Container gerannt oder sonst was.
Du hast per FDP
irgendwelche PHP-Skripts
auf ein Webspace geschoben
und bist dann auf so super-secret-setup gegangen
und hast das eingerichtet.
Du schliefst das alles mit MySQL und PHP.
Also...
Benutzt jemand von euch noch regelmäßig FDP-Server?
Ich habe schon ewig kein FDP mehr benutzt.
Also wirklich.
Ich glaube, ich war per FDP irgendwo eingeloggt.
Die Leute wissen doch nicht mal,
dass man das mit T schreibt.
Ihr meint die Geschichte über SSH.
Das meine ich nicht.
Das gute, klassische
Feilziller oder sowas. FDP.
Ja, genau, so ein Ding.
Vorerst FDP.
Okay, wir gucken uns das Video fertig an.
IT-Zertifikate.
...aufgesprungen und haben ihre individuellen Schulungen
und Zertifizierungen angeboten.
Und das ist auch kein Wunder, denn der Markt für IT-Fachpersonal
war damals so groß und so gefragt wie noch nie zuvor.
Heute wieder.
Im Laufe der 2010er-Jahre kamen dann auch noch verstärkte agile Methoden,
Prozesse usw. hinzu und inzwischen kann man...
Wie gesagt, einfach diagonal, dreidimensional skalieren,
dann ist alles gut. Und Tests braucht man auch nicht,
wenn man das so macht.
...erstaunlich oder, je nach Sichtweise, erschreckend vielen
Themen eine Zertifizierung machen.
Nur stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie läuft so eine
Zertifizierung denn ab? Und das ist natürlich je nach Thema
und vor allem je nach Anbieter ganz verschieden.
Das hängt davon ab. Also Microsoft ist richtig hart drauf.
Habe ich gehört, was Azure-Zertifizierung angeht.
Da musst du deinen Raum filmen, deine Tastatur filmen.
Es darf niemand in den Raum kommen,
du darfst nicht vom Monitor weggucken.
Das läuft darauf raus, dass Leute sich...
Und das ist jetzt kein Spaß, das hat mir wirklich einer von
unseren Microsoft-Schulungsleuten damals erzählt.
Das läuft darauf raus, dass einige Leute,
um diese Azure-Zertifizierung zu machen,
sich mit dem Notebook in der Toilette einschließen,
dass nichts dabei ist, was dem Microsoft-Typ
irgendwie auffallen kann.
Aber es gibt doch einige Gründe, warum das so ist.
Es gibt Grundmuster, die im Großen und Ganzen
durchaus auf alle Angebote zutreffen.
Grundsätzlich ist es in der Regel so, dass man sich
für eine Prüfung anmelden muss, was kostenpflichtig ist.
Und wenn man diese Prüfung bestanden hat,
dann darf man sich zertifiziert für was auch immer nennen.
Wobei ein solches Zertifikat in der Regel nicht unbegrenzt
gültig ist, denn immerhin veralten Technologien ja auch.
Und auf dem Weg soll sichergestellt werden,
dass das zertifizierte Wissen und Können auch halbwegs
zertifiziert werden.
Soviel in der Theorie, ja.
Klingen Zertifizierungen ja sinnvoll, sind sie aber halt nicht.
Wenn man eine solche Zertifizierung einmal bestanden hat,
dann muss man die ...
Leute, leckt der Stream gerade? Hat gerade der Stream geleckt?
Oder alles okay? Der Stream hat geleckt.
Das lag aber an Twitch. Das lag an Twitch.
Ich habe kein ... Oh, doch, 1000 Frames droppt.
Okay, Vodafone hat einen kleinen Schluck aufgehabt gerade.
Amazing, danke für den Sub. Ich hoffe, es geht jetzt wieder.
... ein paar Jahre auch wieder auffrischen,
indem man sie einfach noch mal wiederholt.
Und das zeigt auch ganz gut das Geschäftsmodell,
was dahinter steckt. Die Prüfungen sind, wie gesagt,
kostenpflichtig und auf dem Weg ist für die Anbieter sichergestellt,
dass sie halbwegs regelmäßig wiederkehrende Einnahmen ...
Genau, das ist das, was ich vorhin damit beschreiben wollte,
dass das ein sich selbst versorgendes, geldmachendes Ökosystem ist.
Diese Zertifikats ...
Dieses ganze Zertifikatssammelsurium da.
Das ist genauso wie mit Qualitätszertifizierung.
DIN ISO 9001 und was es nicht alles gibt.
Agiles, Scrum, Masters, Scrum, Agile, Hyper, Mikros, Sprintzertifizierung.
Wenn dich das ein bisschen an die Thematik mit den SSL-Zertifikaten erinnert,
dann ist das eigentlich schon mal ein ganz passender Vergleich.
Das Konzept ist nämlich im Grunde ...
Habt ihr das gesehen? Echsenmensch confirmed.
Dann ist das eigentlich schon mal ein ganz passender Vergleich.
Hä? Hä? Hä? Leute! Keck Alu! Keck Alu! Eindeutig! Eindeutig! Confirmed! Echsenmensch!
Das Konzept ist nämlich im Grunde genommen dasselbe.
Nun möchte man ja aber sicher gehen, dass wenn man eine solche Zertifizierung angeht,
dass man sie dann nach Möglichkeit auch besteht.
Das heißt, weil da ja das eigene Wissen, die Kenntnisse und die Fähigkeiten
detailliert auf dem Prüfstand stehen, möchte man einfach sicher gehen,
dass man möglichst gut vorbereitet ist.
Das stimmt wohl.
Wie machst du das mit Frame für Frame im Video?
Du kannst Komma drücken für Frame zurück und Punkt für Frame nach vorne.
Im Grunde praktisch jede solche Zertifizierung auch einen passenden ...
Vorbereitungskurs! Yo!
... und Bücher sowie weitere Trainingsmaterialien.
Es gibt nicht nur Vorbereitungskurse, es gibt Schulung für die Vorbereitungskurse, Leute!
Ich sag euch, das ist eine Gelddruckmaschine-Zertifikate.
Schulung für ... also eine Schulung vor dem Vorbereitungstermin.
Du machst eine 4-Tages-Schulung, dann kannst du noch einen Vorbereitungstermin machen.
Es ist wirklich Gelddruckmaschine hoch 10 Zertifikate.
Das heißt, hier fallen zusätzliche Ausgaben an und die Bücher,
die musst du vielleicht nicht alle paar Jahre komplett austauschen,
aber trotzdem schadet es auch hier natürlich nicht, von Zeit zu Zeit sicher zu gehen,
dass man zeitgemäße Materialien als Lerngrundlage verwendet.
Wäre ja irgendwie blöd, wenn man die Prüfung nachher deshalb nicht besteht,
weil man von einem Buch nicht die neueste Ausgabe zur Verfügung hatte.
Ja, und gerade Microsoft will dann auch so Dinger wissen wie ...
Ich habe ja mal so eine Beispielprüfung gemacht nach irgendeinem Azure-Kurs.
Was gibt es für Azure-Kurse 400 und 900, AZ 900, AZ 400?
Das waren die Azure-Kurse und ich wollte ...
Ich habe mal so ein paar Testprüfungsfragen gemacht für Azure.
Und ohne Scheiß, Microsoft hat in diesen Prüfungsfragen nicht gesagt,
okay, erklären sie mal, wie man eine VM anlegt in Azure oder worauf.
Nee, nee, in den Prüfungsfragen musstest du schrittweise wissen,
exakt wie du zu klicken hast im Webinterface, um eine VM anzulegen.
Ja, da wird dann sowas abgefragt wie ...
Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht mehr für Azure.
Ich kann es euch aber aus dem Kopf für Google sagen.
Da wurde dann so Sachen abgefragt wie ...
Nach dem Login klicke ich als erstes links oben auf das Hamburger Menü.
Dann scrolle ich runter auf Compute Engine.
Im nächsten Dropdown gehe ich auf VM Instances.
Oben in der Mitte klicke ich auf den Create Button.
Das wollten die wissen in dieser Prüfung.
Die wollten nicht wissen, weiß ich, wie man eine VM anlegen kann.
Die wollten Klick für Klick für Schritt, sonst hast du keine Punkte gekriegt.
Absolut dämlich, komplett hängengeblieben.
Vor allem bei diesen Vorbereitungskursen willst du sicher gehen,
dass die nicht bei irgendwem stattfinden,
sondern dass das von einer Trainerin oder einem Trainer veranstaltet wird.
Offizieller Microsoft Trainer, das ist auch ein Gelddruckding.
Von der Materie hat.
Am besten wäre es, wenn es einen offiziellen Kurs gäbe.
Hamburger Menü, nur mal für den Fall der Fälle,
dass nicht jeder weiß, was ein Hamburger Menü ist.
Hamburger Menü ist sowas.
Das ist ein Hamburger Menü.
Guckt, das sieht aus wie ein Hamburger. Erkennt ihr es?
Chat, wer erkennt die Ähnlichkeiten zum Hamburger?
Das...
Ja, YouTube links oben, genau.
Das nennt sich Hamburger Menü.
Okay, jetzt muss ich auch ein bisschen die Klappe halten.
Wir gucken uns das Video an.
Am besten wäre es, wenn es einen offiziellen Kurs gäbe,
wo die Trainerin oder der Trainer entsprechend, Achtung,
zertifiziert wäre.
Und auch hier dürfte es dich vermutlich nicht groß überraschen,
wenn ich sage, genau dieses Modell gibt es.
Du kannst dich bei vielen der Themen ganz offiziell
als Trainerin oder Trainer zertifizieren lassen.
Du kannst eine Zertifizierung machen,
damit andere Leute bei dir lernen können für die Zertifizierung.
Das ist, was er sagt, ist genau das,
was ich im Vorfeld beschrieben habe oder versucht habe zu beschreiben
mit so selbsterhaltendem Gelddruck-Ökosystem.
Du stehst dafür die natürlich deutlich teurere Prüfung
und du hast vorher die natürlich deutlich teureren Vorbereitungskurse durchlaufen.
Ja, gibt es denn dann auch einen Trainer für die neuen Trainer?
Also, weil irgendjemand muss ja die Zertifizierungstrainer
für die Zertifizierung auch wieder trainieren.
Und es ist halt die Frage, ob der auch eine Zertifizierung dafür braucht
und wer den trainiert hat.
Aber?
Oh doch, ein Zertifizierungstrainer in den Zertifizierungstrainer.
Die ganzen Ausgaben lohnen sich,
denn immerhin verdienst du ja dann mit den Trainings.
Also, abgesehen von dem Anteil,
den du wiederum an den eigentlichen Anbieter abgeben musst,
denn du nutzt ja nun dessen Marke und dessen offizielle Lernmaterialien
und natürlich fällt da unglücklicherweise eine Lizenzgebühr an.
Ach ja.
Unterm Strich läuft dieses Train-the-Trainer-Modell.
Ist ja fast wie bei der IHK,
wo man sich nicht kostenlos die alten Prüfungen angucken kann.
Was ich heute immer noch für ein komplettes Unding halte.
Dass Azubis nicht kostenlos bei der IHK
ein Set alter Prüfungen bekommen können.
Oder zumindest von der Schule.
Nicht nur mit den direkt gebuchten Prüfungen
und den selbst veranstalteten Kursen Geld verdient
und das wie gesagt alle paar Jahre wiederkehrend,
sondern dass das auch indirekt so läuft,
indem man sich halt eine Schar von Multiplikatoren aufbaut,
die man damit ködert,
dass sie wiederum sehr viel Geld verdienen können.
Hat ein bisschen was von einem Schneeballsystem.
Der Maschmeyer wäre stolz drauf.
Klingt so ein bisschen nach...
Wie nennt man das?
Ja, Schneeballsystem.
Oder neudeutsch Strukturvertrieb genannt.
Und das Ganze erinnert unterm Strich
eventuell ein ganz klein wenig
und ganz entfernt an Pyramidensysteme.
Ja, das meinte ich.
Aber wie wir alle ganz genau wissen,
sind die ja immer völlig einwandfrei,
sowohl aus rechtlicher,
als auch aus ethisch-moralischer Sicht.
Ja, legal ist es bestimmt, was sie machen.
Falls du jetzt den Gedanken gehabt hast,
dass dieses ganze Zertifizierungsbusiness
eigentlich nur eine einzige große Gelddruckmaschine ist,
vergiss diesen Gedanken sofort,
denn dieser Gedanke, der ist völlig abwegig.
Ich verstehe eigentlich auch überhaupt nicht,
wie du darauf überhaupt kommen kannst.
Naja, ich weiß,
dass jetzt irgendwo da draußen jemand von euch
dieses Video sieht und sich denkt,
ja, okay, das Geschäftsmodell ist vielleicht
tatsächlich ein bisschen fragwürdig,
aber immerhin bekommt man ja auch was dafür.
Immerhin haben die Anbieter mit den Prüfungen
ja auch hohen Aufwand
und übernehmen außerdem auch eine sehr hohe
und eine sehr große Verantwortung,
denn immerhin geht es darum,
die fachlichen und technischen Kenntnisse
von Entwicklerinnen und Entwicklern zu bewerten.
Ja, in der Theorie schon.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, die Azure-Schulungen,
die ich gemacht habe,
die waren eher teilweise schon cringe,
weil, als Beispiel,
wie sprecht ihr das hier aus?
Wobei, wir können uns das sogar noch aussprechen lassen.
Hier.
Hue.
Ja?
Und unser Trainer,
unser Azure-Trainer,
hat das ausgesprochen,
QE.
Da musste ich immer,
Da musste ich immer leicht cringen,
wenn er das erzählt hat.
Genau.
Gerade was Azure angeht,
war ich bisher nicht begeistert.
Und das ist nun mal kein leichter Job.
Und da bin ich absolut bei dir.
Das ist tatsächlich sehr schwer,
das gut zu machen
und das ist tatsächlich vor allem
auch eine sehr große Verantwortung,
denn immerhin entscheiden diese Zertifizierungen
ja potenziell nicht nur über deine Zukunft,
sondern über die von ganz vielen anderen Menschen auch.
Und insofern müssen solche Prüfungen
schon sehr akkurat ablaufen.
Sie müssen wirklich etwas aussagen.
Es ist schwer, solche Tests zu entwickeln
und da steckt einfach sehr viel Aufwand dahinter.
Und von daher, ja,
wie gesagt, das Geschäftsmodell
mag vielleicht etwas merkwürdig sein,
aber sie bewirken ja damit auch sehr viel Gutes
und damit ist das dann schon okay.
Ja.
Wenn es denn dann mal so wäre.
Ich erzähle dir jetzt mal,
wie das in der Praxis abläuft.
Ich selbst habe nämlich
vier solcher Zertifizierungen hinter mir.
Und wie spricht man Query aus?
Ja, das ist auch so ein bisschen eine Glaubensfrage.
Query?
Ich persönlich bin ja eher der Query-Aussprecher,
aber ich weiß nicht.
Query.
Query, Leute, Query.
Heißt das.
Alles klar?
Jetzt haben wir das Finale geklärt, wie das heißt.
Und wie heißt, Moment, Moment, Moment,
pass mal auf, allerwichtigste.
Warum kann Google mir das nicht vorlesen?
Okay, Cambridge Dictionary kann mir das vorlesen.
GIF.
Die sprechen das ja alle richtig aus.
Warum sagt da keiner GIF?
Und das ist sicherlich nicht repräsentativ
für die ganze Branche.
Und das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her.
Aber es spiegelt, glaube ich, ganz gut wieder,
wie das in der Realität tatsächlich aussieht und abläuft.
Wie spricht man Azure aus?
Also ich glaube nicht,
dass es da so viele unterschiedliche Aussprachen gibt.
Von SQL gibt es tatsächlich wieder mehrere.
Ich persönlich bin auch der SQL-Aussprecher.
Es gibt aber manche, die sagen SQL.
Oh, das ist ja ein Cringe-Witz-Chat.
Azure muss deutsch ausgesprochen werden.
Wie spricht man Azure deutsch aus?
Azure?
Wir legen jetzt eine virtuelle Maschine
in Azure an.
Ich spreche Linux, Linux aus.
Und ich bin da wahrscheinlich näher dran,
an dem, wie das ein Finner aussprechen würde.
Also ich glaube nicht,
dass es da so viele Unterschiede gibt.
dass es so viele Unterschiede gibt.
Als dass ich Linux sagen würde.
Noch besser,
man könnte auch Linux sagen oder sowas.
Linux.
Router oder Rauter?
Ich bin für Router.
Cisco sieht das anders, by the way.
In allen möglichen Cisco-Schulungen
ist es kein Router,
sondern ein Rauter.
Wie sprichst du Ruby aus?
Eindeutig Ruby.
So, wir sollten jetzt aber wirklich mal
das Video fertig gucken.
Sind wir denn stehen geblieben überhaupt?
Ja, aber es spiegelt, glaube ich,
ganz gut wieder,
wie das in der Realität tatsächlich aussieht
und abläuft.
Irgendwie ist das Audio gerade ein bisschen gebuggt.
Nur damals, sondern auch ...
Java oder Java?
Heute noch.
Meine erste Zertifizierung,
das war ungefähr im Jahr 2005,
und zwar zum Microsoft Certified Professional
für Webentwicklung
auf der Basis von ASP.NET.
Oh,
OldschoolASP.NET.
MonkaS.
Das ist aber billig.
Oh, no.
Microsoft Prüfung.
Ich wusste nicht mal,
dass es die in Deutsch gibt.
Wenn die so geil übersetzt ist
wie ihre selbst übersetzten Webseiten,
dann ist es keine gute Idee,
die Prüfung in Deutsch zu machen.
Das war ein ganz großer Fehler.
Ich habe mich damals
für Deutsch entschieden.
Um diese Prüfung ablegen zu können,
musste ich dann vor Ort
zu einem zertifizierten ...
In der Microsoft Prüfung musst du dann nicht
die ...
Keine Ahnung, nicht irgendwie
den Project Folder öffnen,
sondern das Werkzeug
für den Projekt
Mappenmanagement
Projekt
Ordner
oder sowas.
Zu einem zertifizierten
Ordner Schulungsunternehmen,
die das Ganze überwacht haben.
Man kann schon sagen,
dass Microsoft sich der Mühe gegeben hat,
das Ganze mit einer gewissen
Seriosität zu verknüpfen.
Leider kann ich das aber nur
über den äußeren Rahmen sagen.
Die Organisation drumherum,
die Prüfung an sich,
die war komplett absurd.
Das fing mit einer ganz schlechten
Übersetzung an.
Das wundert mich nicht.
Das haben die doch in einer super ...
damals sogar noch schlechteren
Übersetzungssoftware übersetzt.
Aber das eigentlich Erschreckende
war die Qualität der Fragen.
Bei Microsoft, wo sie immer dran denken,
drücken sie Start zum Beenden.
Ich hatte damals so zwei, drei Jahre
Erfahrung mit ASP.NET gehabt,
aber ich hätte die auch mit absolut
keinerlei Erfahrung problemlos
beantworten können.
Du musst dir die Fragen ungefähr
wie folgt vorstellen.
Für jedes Zwischennetz-Antwortobjekt
muss man sich entscheiden,
wenn die Nutzerdatenübertragung
in eine Netztdienst-Anforderungsseite
durchzuführen.
Und als Antwort hast du so Sachen
zur Auswahl, bei denen du zwar
absolut nichts verstehst ...
Klingt nach typischer
Microsoft-Übersetzung.
... wo trotzdem völlig klar ist,
was die richtige Antwort sein muss,
wie beispielsweise
Zwischennetz-Formulare,
Salatschleuder,
und so weiter darüber zu sprechen.
Ja, genau so stelle ich mir
Microsoft-Prüfungen damals vor.
Übrigens noch was Tolles
zum Thema Microsoft-Übersetzung.
Wisst ihr, wie ...
Gibt es sowas überhaupt noch?
WordPad.
WordPad hat doch sowas bestimmt.
Ja, wisst ihr,
wie sich das hier unten nennt?
Erkennt ihr das?
Hier an der Ecke unten,
diese gepunkteten
Dinger,
dass man hier das Fenster ziehen kann.
Wisst ihr, wie sich das offiziell nennt,
dieses Teil,
auf Deutsch,
in Windows?
Ihr wisst vielleicht,
weil ich es schon ein paar Mal erzählt habe.
Ziehkante. Nein, nennt sich nicht.
Nennt sich auch nicht Ecke.
Offizielle Übersetzung,
denke ich, ist immer noch so,
früher war es auf jeden Fall so,
ist Anfasser.
Anfasser.
Anfasser nennt sich das.
Klingt fast schon ein bisschen
kriminell.
Okay.
Komplett absurd.
Ich habe mich nach 30 Minuten
abgegeben,
was alle dort vor Ort
erstaunlicherweise sehr verwundert hat.
Und ich habe diesen MCP mit über 90
Prozent der Punktzahl bestanden.
Ich habe mich dann direkt im Anschluss
auch für die Zertifizierung zum MCP
zu Windows Forms angemeldet,
das war zumindest von der Formulierung
der Fragen nicht abzurufen,
aber inhaltlich war es genauso
unterirdisch. Ich habe genau nichts
für diese Prüfung gelernt.
Ich habe damals keinerlei praktische
Erfahrungen mit Windows Forms gehabt
und ich habe die Prüfung trotzdem
im ersten Anlauf problemlos bestanden
mit nicht ganz so vielen Punkten,
aber unterm Strich immer noch
mit mehr als genug.
Und was soll ich sagen,
seitdem habe ich nicht mehr ganz so
viel Respekt vor diesen Prüfungen.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht,
also die letzten Microsoft Schulungen,
die ich gemacht habe, waren richtig mies
und die Probefragen, die ich gesehen habe,
waren auch dämlich.
Die zweite große Erfahrung,
die ich gemacht habe, das war dann so
sechs, sieben Jahre später,
das war mit Scrum.
Ich habe die Zertifizierung zum
Certified Scrum Master bei der Scrum
Alliance und danach auch noch die
Zertifizierung zum Professional Scrum
Master bei der Scrum.org.
Moment, es gibt eine Zertifizierung
und ich habe das richtig gehört.
Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass es da so viele Abstufungen gibt
für Scrum Master.
Scrum Alliance ist mir in lebhafter
Erinnerung geblieben, denn die Prüfung,
die war entweder sportbillig oder sogar
kostenlos, das weiß ich nicht mehr genau,
aber um teilnehmen zu dürfen,
musste man vorher auf jeden Fall
an einem zweitägigen Workshop teilnehmen.
Natürlich, der hat Geld gekostet.
Ich sage doch, das ist die Lizenz
zum Geldrücken.
Das ist so ein sich selbst
dieser Zertifikats-Shit.
Ich habe jede Menge Erfahrung mit Scrum
gehabt. Hätte, hätte ich den
trotzdem machen müssen.
Und natürlich kam im Workshop von
irgendeiner Teilnehmerin oder einem
Teilnehmer direkt am Anfang die Frage
auf, wie das denn dann im Anschluss
mit der Prüfung laufen würde.
Und die Antwort war, dass wenn man
fleißig mitschreibt, man eigentlich
nicht durchfallen könnte.
Und Wunder, genau so war es auch.
Ja, wir verkaufen halt den Kurs,
machen den banal, weil letztendlich
ist es einfach nur darum,
Geld zu krabben.
Ich habe sehr stark das Gefühl,
dass die Prüfung, die man nun mal
machen muss, wenn man die
Zertifizierung haben möchte, hier
als Hebel verwendet wird, um die
Workshops zu pushen, an denen man
dann richtig Kohle verdient.
Bei denen dann natürlich auch das
vorhin angesprochene Train-the-
Trainer-Konzept greift.
Und das Schlimmste an der ganzen
Geschichte war meiner Meinung nach
aber, dass sich halt noch nicht mal
die Kohle verdient hat.
Also ich muss sagen, die
CCNA-Sachen damals,
die waren, die hatten
durchaus Hand und Fuß.
Die Trainer, die damals
da waren und das abgenommen haben,
die haben einen Rack mitgebracht
mit Cisco-Geräten drin.
Und du musstest dann wirklich
from scratch
Cisco-Switch konfigurieren.
Angefangen mit
Konsolenverbindung richtig
einrichten,
Ports hochfahren,
Netze vergeben und sowas.
Das war gar nicht so schlecht.
Also die haben das gut gemacht,
finde ich.
Und das war bei Scrum.org
nachher genauso und das hinterlässt
doch insgesamt einen ziemlich
faden Beigeschmack.
Ich habe das auch 2007
oder so in dem Dreh gemacht,
seitdem. Also das ist ja
mittlerweile schon längst
abgelaufen.
Also um es kurz zu machen, die
vier Prüfungen, die ich
persönlich erlebt habe, die waren
genau gar nicht dazu geeignet,
sicherzustellen, dass man sich
mit dem Thema auskennt,
geschweige denn, dass man
irgendwelche praktische Erfahrungen
mit dem Thema hätte.
Unterm Strich habe ich mit diesen
Prüfungen nur bewiesen, dass ich
in der Lage bin, den erforderlichen
Betrag zu bezahlen und
dass ich fähig bin, mich durch
einen echt schlecht gemachten
und im Fall von Microsoft auch
noch extrem schlecht übersetzten
Multiple-Choice-Test durchzuraten.
Chat.
Schreibt jemand, er fährt nach
Las Vegas, um sich
zertifizieren zu lassen.
Hey, dann machst du das aber ja,
dann bestätigst du das ja im
Endeffekt.
Du machst die Zertifizierung nicht,
weil du denkst, dass du dadurch
was lernst oder dass es sinnvoll
gewesen ist, Zertifizierung zu
machen. Du machst die
Zertifizierung genau aus dem
Grund, dass es mehr Kohle gibt.
Ohne jetzt die
Sinnhaftigkeit und die
Sinnlosigkeit der Zertifizierung
stellst du ja gar nicht in Frage.
Du sagst ja eigentlich auch, die
ist sinnlos. Du machst das nur,
dass du mehr Geld kriegst.
Vollkommen okay, by the way.
Kann ich verstehen, würde ich
wahrscheinlich auch so machen.
Und das finde ich von heute
aus gesehen rückblickend doch
irgendwo eine ziemliche Zeit und
vor allem Geldverschwendung.
Damals habe ich das anders gesehen,
viel weniger kritisch.
Ich kannte ja auch die ganzen
Hintergründe zum Geschäftsmodell
und so weiter nicht.
Und ich war auch einfach insgesamt
viel weniger erfahren als heute.
Und insofern war ich damals, muss
ich zugeben, schon sehr stolz, dass
ich das jeweils geschafft habe.
Aber unterm Strich und auch das
muss ich dazu sagen, war es dann
eigentlich auch nie für irgendwas
gut, außer vielleicht am
ehesten noch für das eigene Ego,
dass ich halt das Gefühl hatte,
etwas bestanden zu haben.
Aber wenn ich ehrlich bin, ist die
Aussagekraft dieser Prüfung
komplett gleich null.
Und da möchte ich nun vorsichtig
den gleichen Eindruck hatte ich
bei den letzten Escher-Schulungen
auch.
Das CCNA damals war gar nicht so
übel.
Wahllos über einen Kamm scheren.
Denn natürlich kenne ich nicht
alle Zertifizierungen, die es da
draußen gibt.
Und insofern kann ich natürlich
nur auf der Basis dessen urteilen,
was ich bislang erlebt habe.
Und es mag durchaus sein, dass es
auch Zertifizierungen gibt, die
inhaltlich sinnvoll sind.
Wenn es zum Beispiel um regulierte
Branchen geht.
Aber diese Prüfungen sind dann
hoffentlich tiefgreifender und vor
allem aussagekräftiger als das,
was ich erlebt habe.
Das ist dann aber, wenn überhaupt,
wohl eher die Ausnahme.
Was ich stattdessen leider
heutzutage sehr häufig und immer
öfter sehe, das geht eigentlich
in die ganz andere Richtung, das
sind gar nicht mehr so sehr diese
klassischen Zertifizierungen,
sondern bei reinen Online-Anbietern
wie Udemy, Coursera, LinkedIn Learning
und wie die nicht alle heißen,
erworbene Zertifikate.
Und die gehen für mich noch mehr
in diese Richtung.
Hauptsache irgendwas zertifiziert.
Aber die eigentliche Aussagekraft,
die ist praktisch nicht gegeben.
Und da schließt sich der Kreis zu
dem, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe,
nämlich, dass es gar nicht so sehr
darum geht, Menschen bessere
Chancen zu ermöglichen, sondern
dass es eigentlich darum geht, unter
dem Vorwand, Menschen angeblich
bessere Chancen ermöglichen zu
wollen, einfach nur Geld zu
verdienen.
Und das finde ich sehr schwierig.
Vor allem, weil ich immer wieder
sehe, wie viele Entwicklerinnen und
Entwickler sich darauf stützen, im
Glauben und im Vertrauen damit etwas
geschafft zu haben, etwas erreicht zu
haben, was sie in ein gutes Licht
rücken könnte.
So wie ich das damals ja auch geglaubt
habe, aber am Ende des Tages haben
sie eigentlich nur eins erreicht,
nämlich einen Online-Anbieter
noch reicher und noch erfolgreicher
zu machen.
Und das finde ich persönlich sehr
schlimm.
Das finde ich traurig.
Und da tun mir auch all die
Entwicklerinnen und Entwickler leid,
die mit großen Hoffnungen in diese
Prüfungen gehen und die sich gar nicht
bewusst sind, dass es an der Stelle
null um sie oder um ihre Karriere
geht, sondern einzig und allein um ihr
Geld.
Tja, wie siehst du das?
Ähnlich.
Welche Erfahrungen hast du denn mit
Zertifizierungen gemacht?
Gute, schlechte?
Wie liefen denn deine Prüfungen ab,
wenn du schon welche abgelegt hast?
Und haben dir Zertifizierungen
tatsächlich schon mal weitergeholfen?
Oder fällt das für dich auch eher in
die Abteilung, ja, kann ich
auch gerne irgendwo mitschicken, aber
macht eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Schreib deine Meinung und deine
Gedanken zu dem Thema gerne einmal
unten in die Kommentare.
Und wenn du darüber noch ein bisschen
mehr...
Ich hab, by the way, nur mal so.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ich ein
Zertifikat habe für Visual Basic 6?
Ich wollt's nur mal erwähnt haben.
Visual Basic 6.
Dann komm auch gerne auf unseren
Discord-Server und den Link dorthin,
den findest du auch unten in der
Videobeschreibung.
Unabhängig davon hoffe ich natürlich,
dass dir das Video heute gefallen hat.
Und wenn ja, dann würde ich mich sehr
freuen, wenn du es mit deinen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen teilst.
Und für heute wünsche ich dir dann
jetzt erstmal noch einen schönen
Sonntagabend.
Morgen dann einen guten Start in die
neue Woche.
Pass, wie immer, gut auf dich auf,
bleib gesund und dann sehen wir uns
kommende Woche im nächsten Video wieder.
Und in diesem Sinne, mach's gut.
Ciao.
Jo, see you.
Alter.
Eieiei.
Na Chico?
Na Chico, was ist?
Meine Katze ist da.
Chico?
Jo, Chico, was los?
Na?
Die, die ihr unten rechts seht im Bild,
ist da.
Alle, alle Abos, ihr könnt, ihr könnt
jetzt mitmachen, Leute.
Wupp, pet in den Chat.
Wenn ihr Chico mitstreicheln wollt.
Chico, komm her.
Jetzt will Chico, Chico ist schon wieder weg.
Chico haut schon wieder ab.
Das ist übrigens nicht Chico auf Wupp, pet.
Ich muss Chico mal wieder rauslassen, ja.
So.
Was?
Ich musste Adlesionszertifizierung machen,
wo mich ein Hinder über Webcam plus AI
überwacht.
Und wenn die haben dich mit AI überwacht,
ich, du warnst.
LinkedIn Learning?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es sowas überhaupt gibt.
Retterzertifizierung, ja, das
habe ich auch gehört, dass die ein bisschen
anspruchsvoller sein sollen.
Ist auch ein Instrument für Arbeitgeber,
die Bewerberschwelle im Schulungsschul...
Ganz ehrlich, die Leute sollen einfach
drauf gucken, ob die Bewerber auf das Profil
passen. Und, also ganz
ehrlich,
da verpassen sie wahrscheinlich die besten
Kandidaten, wenn sie nach Schulung gehen.
Selbst schuld.
Stimmt, woher wissen wir das überhaupt?
Der hat kein Trainerzertifikat.
Und woher, warum
guckt ihr überhaupt meinen Stream? Ich bin auch nicht
zertifizierter Twitch-Streamer.
Und, und vor allem, wer hat den
Trainer zertifiziert?
Sehr, sehr schwierig.
Leute, morgen früh...
Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Follows.
Morgen früh
bin ich
wieder so am Start.
8.30 Uhr bis 9.00 Uhr
ungefähr geht's los.
Aufwachen, streamen.
Heute war ja so eine spontane
Aktion.
Der einzige Tag, an dem ich eine Woche
wirklich, also mein einziger fester
Streaming-Tag ist tatsächlich sonntags
morgens. 8.30 Uhr bis 9.00 Uhr
geht's irgendwie los und dann so bis
Mittag erst sein.
Bin ich wieder am Start.
Übrigens, Wurzelserb, danke für den
Sub, hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Deswegen, ich geh
jetzt auf.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis morgen früh, macht's gut.
C U